I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Happy Wednesday, everybody. A very happy Wednesday.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做专属于你们的终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们是《办公室》剧组。大家周三快乐。非常快乐的周三。
This is one of the most exciting Wednesdays for me. This might be one of my happiest Wednesdays. Office ladies listeners, we have a special guest today. The one, the only, Steve Carell. We have been waiting for this ever since the beginning of the podcast. We are so excited to have him on and you guys are going to love it. We are dedicating this entire episode to Steve. He's going to talk about all of his time on The Office playing Michael Scott.
对我来说，这是最令人兴奋的周三之一。这可能是我最快乐的周三之一。办公室女士的听众们，我们今天迎来了一位特别嘉宾。唯一的，独一无二的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。从播客一开始，我们就一直在期待这一刻。能请到他做客，我们感到非常兴奋，你们也一定会爱死这一期的。我们将这一整集都献给史蒂夫。他将谈论他在《办公室》饰演迈克尔·斯科特的全部时光。
We could not be more excited for you to hear it. So I hope you guys, when you listen, the thing that just warmed my heart was for me, it was just three friends getting to hang out who had missed each other and hadn't seen each other in so long. So I just hope as you listen, you get to feel that with us. It was like no time had passed. We just were so happy to see our old friend. I really feel like we captured what it's like to sit on set with Steve Carell.
听到这个消息，我们再兴奋不过了。所以希望你们在收听时——最温暖我心的，对我而言，就是三个想念彼此、好久不见的老朋友终于聚在一起。所以我只希望你们在收听时能感受到这一点。感觉就像时光从未流逝。我们看到老朋友感到无比高兴。我真的觉得我们捕捉到了和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起坐在片场的感觉。
People always ask us, what's it like to work with Steve Carell? This interview captures what it's like. These are the conversations. This is how we would laugh. Yeah. These were our Monday morning chats after the weekend. Absolutely. Before we get to the interview, we do want to give a big shout out to our Facebook fan
人们总是问我们，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起工作是什么感觉？这段采访就捕捉到了那种感觉。这就是我们的对话方式。这就是我们大笑的样子。没错。这就是我们周末过后周一早上的闲聊。绝对是的。在进入采访之前，我们想对我们的Facebook粉丝
page. I hopped on there and I wrote a message. I had to literally figure out Facebook in order to do it. You did. You were like, I don't know my password. I didn't know anything. I had an old account that was like five years old or something. But I went on there and I asked you guys, what do you want us to ask Steve Carell?
主页表示由衷的感谢。我登录并写了一条消息。我为了发这条消息，简直现学了怎么用Facebook。确实。你当时说：“我不知道我的密码。”你什么都不知道。我有一个五年前的旧账号什么的。但我上去了，问了大家一个问题：你们想让我们问史蒂夫·卡瑞尔什么？
And oh my gosh, did you show up for us? It was amazing. So awesome. You guys sent in thousands of fantastic questions. I also want to give a big shout out to Nikki, who moderates the Facebook fan page because she helped us go through and pick out some of your most asked questions. And we asked Steve your questions. And some of the questions are so good.
天哪，你们太给力了。太棒了。太棒了。你们发来了成千上万个精彩的问题。我还要对Facebook粉丝页面的版主尼基表示感谢，因为她帮我们筛选出了你们问得最多的一些问题。我们向史蒂夫提出了你们的问题。有些问题真是太好了。
I would have never thought of them. I know. And they made us laugh and you'll hear it. You'll hear it. All right. Let's take a break. And when we come back, our interview with Steve Carell. Jenna, I am so excited because-
我自己绝对想不出来。我懂的。它们让我们哈哈大笑，你们待会儿就能听到。你们会听到的。好了。我们休息一下。回来后，就是我们对史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的采访。詹娜，我太兴奋了，因为——
Yeah, so sitting next to me, Steve, it's a nice girl in the studio on office, ladies. We're all here in our glasses. Remember, we didn't have these when we worked on the show together. Did we all three wear glasses? The very last season, I really needed them for table reads. Right. For reading. Yes.
对，坐在我身边的史蒂夫，工作室里有个漂亮女孩，在《办公室》里。我们都戴着眼镜坐在这里。记住，我们一起拍剧时可没有这些。我们三个都戴眼镜了吗？最后一季时，台词围读时我真的很需要它们。没错。为了阅读。是的。
But look at us now. Now we're here. Free people. I know. In need of eyewear. Yeah. Should I just kick it off with our very first question we always ask? We have a favorite first question.
但看看现在的我们。现在我们在这儿。自由人了。我懂的。都需要配镜。是啊。我是不是该直接抛出我们必问的第一个问题？我们有一个最爱的第一个问题。
We have all of our guests. Okay. Here it is. It is. It's really hard. It's really hard. Ready? How did you get your job on the office?
我们对所有的嘉宾都会问。好吧。问题来了。就是这个。真的很难。真的很难。准备好了吗？你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？
I auditioned. I have to say the audition for the office was unlike any audition I've ever had. And I'm sure you had the same experience because it felt like it was a workshop. It didn't feel like an audition. There didn't seem to be a ton of pressure. You just went in and they had a camera, but you didn't think there was anyone outside of the, you know, the one or two people that was that were in the room. So it was very low keyed and very supportive.
我试镜了。我必须说，《办公室》的试镜和我经历过的任何试镜都不同。我敢肯定你也有同感，因为感觉它像是一个工作坊，而不是一次试镜。感觉不到什么压力。你走进去，里面有摄像机，但你觉得房间里除了那一两个人之外，没有别人了。所以氛围非常轻松，也非常具有支持性。
I remember we did a screen test together because after I auditioned something like seven times, I made it to the end, I guess, and it was like I was one of the final four and they paired me up with you for a couple of scenes. That was crazy. I'd never done something like that before. I said, I anybody but her, you're like, I don't care. No chemistry. What is her name?
我记得我们一起做过试镜测试，因为在我试镜了大约七次之后，我进入了最后阶段，我想我是最后四个人之一，他们把我跟你配对演了几场戏。太疯狂了。我以前从未做过那样的事情。我说，除了她谁都行，你却说，我不在乎。毫无化学反应。她叫什么名字？
Gemma. Gemma Fisker. I don't like it. I don't think it's going to work. I don't think Gemma Fisker is going to be on the show. No, I remember auditioning with you and I remember how grounded you were instantly in your character. And I thought, you know, when you read with someone, you don't know who they are as a
杰玛。杰玛·费斯克。我不喜欢。我觉得行不通。我觉得杰玛·费斯克不会出现在这部剧里。不，我记得和你一起试镜，我记得你对角色的代入感是多么的扎实。我想，你知道的，当你和某人对词时，你并不了解对方是一个
person. Yeah. And you immediately think, well, that's that's who she is clearly because you can't separate it at that point. But then you find out like everyone has completely different personalities than the characters are portrayed. And it's kind of amazing. Like once I remember, can I tell a story like right off the bat?
什么样的人。是的。然后你立马就会想，好吧，她显然就是那样的人，因为当时你无法将演员和角色分离开来。但后来你发现，每个人的真实性格都和他们所扮演的角色完全不同。这真是太神奇了。比如我记得，我能一开始就讲个故事吗？
Oh my gosh. When we were at our first studio, our first sound stage out in Culver City, and we were shooting the pilot and I was at craft service and I had taken a can of Diet Coke or something out of the six pack. And you know, there was that plastic, the carrying six pack thing. And I started breaking it down. I started cutting the edges before I threw it in the trash, you know, because of the dolphins.
天哪。当我们在卡尔弗城的第一个工作室、第一个摄影棚时，我们在拍试镜集（Pilot），我在餐饮服务区，我从六连装里拿了一罐健怡可乐什么的。你知道的，那种塑料的六连装提手。我开始把它拆开。我在把它扔进垃圾桶之前把边缘剪碎了，你知道的，为了海豚。
Right. And I remember you walking up and commending me for doing that. And that stuck with me like, oh, yeah, I was just kind of doing it as a courtesy to the dolphins. Yes. And I remember you kind of giving me a bat on the back and saying, hey, good for you. Nice job. That is such a specific memory to remember.
对。我记得你走过来，称赞我这样做。这深深印在我的脑海里，我想，哦，是的，我当时其实只是对海豚表示一下礼貌。是的。我记得你拍拍我的背说：“嘿，真棒。干得好。”这是一个多么具体的记忆啊。
I did. Like it's one of my strongest memories from the first episode. I thought, she's so nice. That's so, it's so nice to be with nice people. I guess that was the takeaway. Yeah. Like, oh, this is going to be great. Right.
我真的记得。就像这是我对第一集最深刻的记忆之一。我想，她太好了。能和善良的人在一起真是太好了。我想这就是我得到的感悟。是的。就像，哦，这会很棒的。没错。
Dolphin lover. Mm hmm. You know, I do that at home. I probably said, I do that at home. Yeah. Yeah. Love to see it. And we should shout out to all the people out there.
海豚爱好者。嗯哼。你知道，我在家里也这么做。我大概说过，我在家里也这么做。是的。是的。喜闻乐见。我们也应该向外面所有人大声呼吁。
Cut the plastic. Cut the plastic. Don't, you know. Yeah. Keep the plastic down. Yeah. For one thing. That's right.
剪断塑料。剪断塑料。别，你知道的。是的。把塑料剪碎。是的。为了某种原因。没错。
This is going to be a PSA. It is so funny though, like where your brain goes because my strongest memory of the pilot is how you had to go down those stone steps outside to get like to crafting everything. You know, like you had to go outside the building down these stone staircase. And Oscar and I were leaving at the same time and he, we had done sketch comedy together for years, right? So we just went back to our silly shtick and he goes, let's walk down the stairs together the same way.
这将是一则公益广告。不过太搞笑了，你的脑回路是怎么样的，因为我对试镜集最深刻的记忆是，你不得不走外面那些石阶下去，去拿道具什么的。你知道的，你得走出大楼，走下这些石阶。奥斯卡和我正同时离开，而且我们一起做过好几年的素描喜剧，对吧？所以我们又回到了我们傻里傻气的把戏上，他说，我们用同样的姿势一起走下楼梯吧。
And I said, okay, Oscar, we started to go down the stairs with our arms flinging about. And we turned and the whole like producing team was walking behind us, like Terry Weinberg, Howard Klein, all of those people. And I was like, Oscar, there's a bunch of people behind us. He goes, then we have to keep doing it. Yeah, you have to own it. Yeah. So I'm like, okay, that's one thing I remember.
我说，好啊，奥斯卡，我们挥舞着胳膊开始下楼梯。我们一转身，整个制作团队正跟在我们身后，比如特里·温伯格、霍华德·克莱恩，所有那些人。我就说，奥斯卡，我们身后有一群人。他说，那我们得继续。对，你得敢作敢当。对，所以我心想，好吧，这是我记住的一件事。
But then you find out later on those intimidating people weren't intimidating at all. No. Everyone who was completely. So nice and rooting for us. Yeah. Everyone was in the same boat. I have a question that came from our office ladies fan group. This is from Carly D. Carly would like to know, what was your process and inspiration behind
但后来你发现，那些看似吓人的家伙一点也不吓人。没错。每个人都完全。那么善良，而且都在为我们加油。是的。大家都在一条船上。我有一个问题来自我们的“办公室女士”粉丝群。这是卡莉·D提出的。卡莉想知道，你塑造迈克尔时的心路历程和灵感来源是什么？
playing Michael? How did you craft this character? I remember meeting with Greg Daniels up at a deli, like on the top of Mulholland. And we didn't know each other at all. And it's before, it's before I got the part, actually, he, you know, he was, I think he was meeting with some of the people who were sort of in the mix, the final mix for Michael. And we just discussed the character and talked about what his foibles are and what is his dreams and hopes and, and I had a pretty specific take at that point.
你是如何雕琢这个角色的？我记得在穆荷兰山顶上一家熟食店见到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我们当时根本不认识。那是，其实是在我得到这个角色之前，你知道的，他当时在和一些有望出演迈克尔的最终候选人见面。我们只是讨论了这个角色，谈论他的缺点是什么，他的梦想和希望是什么，当时我对这个角色有一个相当具体的看法。
And it wasn't Ricky Gervais's, you know, and I, and I've told this story a million times that I chose not to watch the British version because I just didn't want that to influence whatever this version was going to be. And because he was so, he was clearly so great at it and was such a distinctive character. I didn't want to do an impression of him. I remember you telling me that, and I remember telling you that I had chosen to watch the entire British series and completely copy Lucy Davis and was basically doing a Lucy Davis impression to get the job.
而且这和瑞奇·热维斯的版本不一样，你知道的，而且我讲过一百万遍这个故事了，我选择不看英国版，因为我不想让它影响到这个新版本会是什么样。而且因为他显然演得太棒了，是一个如此鲜明的角色。我不想模仿他。我记得你告诉我这件事，我也记得我告诉你，我选择看完全部英国剧集，并完全复制露西·戴维斯，基本上就是靠模仿露西·戴维斯来得到这份工作的。
So not true. Yeah. But also kind of true until, you know, especially for the pilot, because we were doing it word for word. And I was like, I think she nailed it. Like, I don't know how to say the line better than that, so I guess I'm just going to go with what she did. Well, but I remember you saying you'd never seen it and I didn't really have that information
完全不是真的。但也算是真的，直到，你知道的，特别是对于试镜集来说，因为我们是在一字不差地照着演。我就想，我觉得她演得太绝了。我不知道怎么能把台词说得比她更好，所以我想我只能照着她演的来了。嗯，但我记得你说过你从来没看过，而我脑子里并没有这个信息。
in your brain. I didn't because, you know, I watched like a minute of just to get a sense of the tone of the show, sort of how, how dark and very dry, very dour kind of bleak, which I loved. I loved how still it was at times. But his character was so specific, I thought, no, I can't because that's what I'll want to do. I won't see it any other way. And I think Greg agreed with that as sort of a template for doing it.
我确实没有，因为，你知道的，我只看了一分钟左右，为了感受一下这部剧的基调，那种黑暗、非常干瘪、非常严厉、有点凄凉的基调，我很喜欢。我很喜欢它有时那种静止感。但他的角色太具体了，我想，不，我不能看，因为那会成为我想去模仿的方向。我不会以任何其他方式来看待它。我想格雷格也同意这一点，作为表演的模板。
And we were definitely on the same page in terms of who this guy could be and could become. And early on, I started thinking about an arc, too, like where, where, because you hope, you know, you don't go in thinking this is just going to be a pilot or this is just going to be six episodes. The hope is the character starts here and ends up way somewhere else. There's no way of really knowing where a character is going to end in the last episode. But, but I kind of in my mind, I had a plan like because these characters, the hope was that all of these characters would change and evolve and grow.
而且在探讨这家伙是谁、以及他能成为什么样的人方面，我们绝对是同频的。早期的时候，我也开始构思一个角色的成长弧光，比如，因为你抱着希望，你知道的，你不会觉得这只是一集试镜剧集，或者这只是六集短剧。希望是这个角色从这里开始，最后成长到完全不同的地方。你没法真正知道一个角色在最后一集会走向何方，但是，但在我的脑海里，我有一个计划，因为这些角色——希望是所有这些角色都会改变、演变和成长。
And that's part of what's fun about watching a show is to see progress in these characters. So that was that was sort of the plan going in. That was sort of the hope. It was one of those parts that you just pray that you get because at well, you know, at that point, certainly, we're all just happy to be working, but on top of it, it just seemed like what a what a perfect thing to be a part of and everyone who I met who had been involved with it seemed great and smart and nice and kind. And all of those things just made it so appealing to to want to be, I was, you know, crossing
这也是观看一部剧的乐趣所在，那就是看到这些角色的进步。所以这差不多就是最初的计划。差不多就是这种期盼。这是一个你会祈祷自己能得到的角色，因为当时，你知道的，在那个阶段，当然，我们都只是高兴能有工作可做，但除此之外，这似乎是一个多么完美的参与项目啊，我遇到的所有与它有关的人看起来都那么棒、那么聪明、那么善良、那么友善。所有这些都让它对我想加入充满了吸引力，我当时，你知道的，一直在。
my fingers. Oh, I know. I remember thinking like, I can do this, like this one I can do. Yeah. But that was Pam. And I didn't get it. But then I got to be the accountant. And then I was like, no, I can really do this.
交叉双指祈祷。哦，我懂的。我记得当时想：我能演这个，这个我可以。但那是帕姆。我没演成。但后来我成了会计。然后我就想，不，我真的可以演这个。
Have you ever worked in an office in real life or ever had a boss like Michael Scott? No. No. No, I never have. Not an office worker. I did a lot of, you know, I did a lot of waiting tables. I sold wine over the phone at one point. How do you sell wine over the phone?
你在现实生活中上过班吗，或者有过像迈克尔·斯科特这样的老板吗？没有。没有。没有，我从来没有。不是办公室职员。我做过很多，你知道的，我当过很多次服务生。我还在电话里卖过葡萄酒。你怎么在电话里卖葡萄酒？
Exactly. I mean, you can't taste it. How does it? It's a beautiful bottle. Well, you describe it based on, but we didn't get to drink the wine, but you have to describe a wine based on a, you know, a paragraph that they've written on each on each wine and my right characteristics of each wine. It's a hard sell.
没错。我的意思是，你又尝不到。怎么卖？这是一瓶好酒。嗯，你根据，但我们喝不到酒，但你必须根据，你知道的，他们给每款酒写的一段话来描述一款酒，并写下每款酒的特点。这很难推销。
Believe me. Hello. Do you like wine? I mean. Click. Oh, my God. Okay. Was the office your first lead role?
相信我。喂。你喜欢葡萄酒吗？我的意思是。挂断。哦，天哪。好吧。那是你的第一个主演角色吗？
Yeah. I think it was. I had done, it was a, it was really fun to do. But I played a crazy Greek chef on a sitcom with Annie Potts and Tim Curry. So that's, that's the, that's the sitcom that I had done. And I did it, I did a show just before the office starring Tom Papa, a really funny comedian. And he had a show. Come to Papa.
是的。我想是的。我演过，那真的很有趣。但我曾在一部情景喜剧中饰演一个疯狂的希腊厨师，和安妮·波茨、蒂姆·库里合作。所以，那是我演过的情景喜剧。在《办公室》之前，我还演过一部由汤姆·帕帕主演的剧，他是一个非常搞笑的喜剧演员。他有一部剧。来找帕帕。
Come to Papa. And he was, he was so great. And this show, you know, only lasted a few episodes. So I, I went from that and then auditioned for the office when that, when that ended. But no, I'd never done a lead, I'd never done a lead role. Cause I, I have such a memory of you, Steve, sitting over on that little sofa at front reception or the chair sometimes that was in front of Michael's office, just studying your lines cause you, you would have to carry every scene.
来找帕帕。他太棒了。这部剧，你知道的，只播了区区几集。所以，当那个结束时，我就从那儿转过来去试镜了《办公室》。但没有，我从来没演过主角，从来没演过主角。因为我对你印象太深了，史蒂夫，你总是坐在前台接待处的那张小沙发上，有时是迈克尔办公室门前的椅子上，一直在背台词，因为你得撑起每一场戏。
And I just breezed through and said something snarky to Kevin and then breezed out, you know, for the most part. But I always thought, was there a lot of pressure to be the lead and have to carry all of that? Not, not with that group of people because I felt like everyone was an equal component of that show. I didn't feel that way. I didn't feel like I was carrying any more load than anyone else because when you think about it, you know, yeah, I had a lot of dialogue, but everyone was there all the time.
而我总是轻描淡写地走过去，对凯文说句刻薄的话，然后就飘然离去，你知道的，大部分时候都是这样。但我一直在想，作为主角必须扛起这一切，压力是不是很大？不会，和那群人在一起不会，因为我觉得每个人都是这部剧里同等重要的组成部分。我没有那种感觉。我不觉得自己承担了比其他人更多的负担，因为你想想看，好吧，我的台词确实很多，但每个人从头到尾都在现场。
And even if you were in the background of a scene, you're still acting, you're still active, you, like all of us had character stuff going on at all times. So I don't think enough can be said for the fact that to be, to just be present on that set, everyone was working really hard, but it didn't, it didn't, I don't want to make it sound like it was hard work because it wasn't. It was really fun because everyone was there supporting each other. So no, I never felt, I never felt like any undo pressure. And also the writing was so good that at a certain point it became very easy to make
而且，即使你在一场戏里当背景板，你仍然在演戏，你仍然很活跃，你，就像我们所有人一样，随时都有自己的角色支线在上演。所以，无论怎么强调这一点都不为过：为了能出现在那个片场，每个人都在极其努力地工作，但这并没有——我不想把它说得好像工作很苦，因为一点也不苦。真的很有趣，因为每个人都在那里互相支持。所以，不，我从没觉得有过什么不当的压力。而且剧本写得太好了，以至于到了一定阶段，记台词变得非常容易，因为你开始准确理解编剧的写作思路，以及他们是如何为我们量身定制台词的，比如针对我们的角色和我们所有人的声线。所以我觉得如果台词写得好，通常就比较容易记住，因为它合乎逻辑。
and memorize lines because you started to understand exactly how the writers were writing it and how they were also writing to us, like to our characters and to all of our voices. So I find that if dialogue is really good, it's generally pretty easy to remember because it makes sense. That's right. I always think about that too. If it's well written, I have no problem. And then our joke is we'd never make it on a medical show because all of the things they
没错。我总是这么想。如果剧本写得好，我就完全没问题。然后我们开玩笑说，我们永远没法去演医疗剧，因为他们必须语速极快地吐出一大堆专业术语，我会觉得：哦不，我可不去试镜那个。我会一败涂地的。是的。不，那太难了。所以，史蒂夫，我们在这档播客中多次谈到，我们对你的稳定性、一致性以及你的领导力充满了感激之情，以至于有粉丝莎拉·H写信说：“我们听说史蒂夫在片场是多么富有支持性和专业精神，我很想听听史蒂夫关于在工作中定下基调和营造支持性环境的看法或建议。”
have to just quickly rapid fire off, I'd be like, oh no, I'm not, I'm not going to audition for that. I'll be a disaster. Yeah. No, that would be tough. So Steve, we have talked about many times on this podcast, just about our gratitude for your just stability and consistency and your leadership, so much so that a fan wrote in Sarah H. and said, we've heard how supportive and professional Steve is on set, and I would
首先得说，我其实挺棒的。所以有些东西是刻在基因里的。我是说，你以前穿过一件T恤，上面写着“我很棒”，对吧？没错。一件印着我脸的T恤，好再次强调那就是我。你这么说真是太好了。
love to hear Steve's perspective or advice on setting the tone at work and fostering a supportive environment. Let's start by saying I am pretty great. So some of it's just in your DNA. I mean, you had a shirt you would wear that would said, I'm fantastic, right? That's right. A shirt with my face on it, so just reiterate that it's me. That's really nice of you to say.
但话说回来，我觉得自己只是这个非常独特的演员集体的一部分，所以我从来不觉得自己有什么了不起。我认为格雷格是我们的领导者和导师，在这个世界观的构建上，他掌控全局，而且每个人都太好了。每个人对彼此都那么友善，以至于我从未觉得事情本该有别的样子，从服装到编剧，再到所有的剧组人员、餐饮、餐饮服务，每个人都觉得自己是其中的一部分。另一部分原因在于，我真诚地相信，我们每个人都很清楚，不管是谁在看，也不管它在收视率方面能维持多久，哪怕播了一两季或三季就被砍了，我深信——我想我们所有人都为能有机会参与这部剧并在一起工作感到无比高兴和感恩。这真的很特别，而且我们在当时就已经意识到它是多么特别了。
But again, I felt like I was part of this very unique ensemble, and so I never thought of myself that way. I thought of Greg as our leader and our mentor in terms of this world, and he oversaw everything, and everyone was so nice. Everyone was so kind to each other that I never got a sense that it should be any other way than just in terms of the production of the show, like from wardrobe to the writers, to all of the crew, catering, craft service, everybody felt like they were part of something. And the other part of it is, I believe sincerely that every one of us knew, no matter who watched
嗯哼。确实如此。我总是对剧本超级感激，因为你知道的，当你演一档即兴喜剧秀或小品喜剧秀之类的节目时，总会有一个人一心只想抖包袱、只想出风头、只想当搞笑担当，结果把整场演出都给毁了，但在我们的剧里，我从来没有这种感觉。就像，如果菲莉丝抛出了最棒的包袱，她能把全场炸翻，奥斯卡或克里德也是如此。这都无所谓。笑点来自每一个人。这是一个真正的创意集体，编剧就是这样写的，格雷格也是这样对待我们的。
it or whether it had any sort of longevity in terms of viewership, even if we got canceled after a season or two or three, I was so, I think we were all so happy and thankful for the time that we got to work on the show and to be with one another. It was really, it just, it was a special thing, and we were aware of how special it was in the moment. Mm-hmm. For sure. I always was just super thankful for the writing because it was like, you know, when you do
就像，格雷格看了一场戏后会说：“不，你知道吗？让吉姆来抖这个包袱效果不对。我们换一下，让斯坦利说这句词。”没错。然后全场都被惊艳到了。所以我一直都有这种感觉，我觉得格雷格为我们定下了这个基调：每个人都有上场的机会。你完全说对了。
an improv show or a sketch comedy show or something, and there's one person that wants the joke, wants the joke, wants the joke, and they just kill the show, I never felt that on our show. It was like, if Phyllis had the best button, she could level the room or Oscar or Creed. It didn't matter. Like, the jokes came from everyone. It was a real creative collective, and the writers wrote that way, and Greg treated us that way.
每个人都有展现自己的时刻。不仅如此，其他人也都乐见其成。其他人都给予支持。没有任何怨恨，也没有任何个人主义。而且，为什么不呢？这才是正确的做事方式。我想你看剧的时候就能发现这一点，因为整部剧有一种平和感。没人，所有人，一切都很好，你知道的，每个人都在，每个人都在，每个人都在
Like, Greg could look at a scene and be like, no, you know what? It's not working with Jim getting the laugh. Let's flip that and let's have Stanley say it. Right. And then it just floored everyone. And so I always felt that way, and I feel like Greg set that tone for us that, like, everybody gets to play. You're exactly right.
彼此相爱，我是说作为演员的我们以及超越角色的我们。我对会议室的戏感到无比兴奋，因为那是我们快节奏对白的高潮。我是说，迈克尔坐在前面，但字面意义上房间里的每个人都有自己的小包袱或表情，看着太有趣了。几乎没法顺利拍完。哦，我们确实没拍好。天哪，我们NG了太多次。好吧，大家对你聊聊拍摄《办公室》时的一些最爱记忆感到非常兴奋。
Everyone got their shot. Not just that, but everyone else loved it. Everyone else was supportive of it. There was no resentment, no ego involved. And like, why not? That's the way to do it. And I think you can see it when you watch the show, because there is a calm to it. Like, no one's, everyone, it's all good, you know, everyone's, everyone is, everyone's
具体来说，他们很好奇你有没有最喜欢的某一集，这我觉得就像在问“你最喜欢哪个孩子”一样。太难了。太难了。是的。这太难了。你知道的，我的最后一集，说到走心，那一集拍起来真的很不容易。
loving each other, you know, in terms of us as actors and people beyond the characters. I get so excited for conference room scenes, because those were our rapid fire things. I mean, Michael is up there, but literally every single person in the room has either a bit or a look, and it's just so fun to watch. Almost impossible to get through. Oh, and we didn't. Oh my God, we left so much. Well, people are very excited for you to talk about some of your favorite memories of shooting
但与此同时我也很喜欢它，因为那是迈克尔的终局之战。那是高潮所在，某种程度上展现了他的成长——他不需要轰轰烈烈的欢送，不需要盛大的派对。他可以按照自己的方式与所有的朋友告别，不需要任何大张旗鼓的庆祝。所以，我真的很享受让这个角色在那个时刻演变到那种境界。人们总是会提到这一集，那就是“晚餐派对”。“晚餐派对”绝对名列前茅，而且我们是在编剧罢工结束后回归拍的第一集。所以那是我们拍的第一场戏。
the office. Specifically, they're curious if you have a favorite episode, which I think is like asking, do you have a favorite child? It's very hard. It's so hard. Yeah. That is hard. You know, my last one, talk about heart, it was a really difficult episode to do.
我知道你们探讨过这个，但我认为每个人都太渴望回去工作了，而且真的非常想念彼此。这是一集酝酿已久、蓄势待发的剧集。它又是如此诡异，主题上有点晦涩，疯狂，还有棒极了的客串和视觉笑料，但在很多方面它也非常黑暗、非常悲伤，且充满了情感纠葛。所以那一集里发生了很多事。我也很喜欢那一集。
But I also loved it at the same time, because it was sort of that end game for Michael. It was that the culmination, the sort of showing the growth that he didn't need the big send-off. He didn't need the big party. He could say goodbye to all of his friends on his own terms without any of the fanfare. And so that I really enjoyed having that character evolve to that point in that moment. And people always point to this one, but dinner party. Dinner party's up there, and we'd come back after the writer strike. So that was the first thing that we had shot.
直到我们剖析它并稍微谷歌了一下，我们才意识到，显然它在刚播出时是个彻头彻尾的票房毒药。它并不是粉丝的最爱。它不是今天这个样子，但当时人们并不买账。总体来说，这部剧刚上映时也是个巨大的票房毒药。确实如此。这是一种需要慢慢体味的艺术，我猜。另一个符合你刚才说的、一开始人们并不喜欢的剧集是《斯科特的 tots》（Scott's Tots）。
I know you've discussed it, but I think everyone was so ready to get back to work and had really missed each other. And this is an episode that had just been sitting there waiting to happen for a while. And it's so weird and kind of dense in thematically and crazy and had great guest appearances and great sight gags, what was also really dark in a lot of ways and very sad and kind of emotionally fraught. So there was a lot going on in that one. So I like that one too.
我很喜欢拍那一集，因为它太糟糕了，但我觉得它极其深刻地展现了这个家伙的人格特质，因为他的发心绝对是好的，而且有一颗巨大的心，但错得离谱。没有后续兑现。我想当时有一个对着镜头独白（Talking Head）的桥段，大意是：在我这辈子做过的所有蠢事中，这一件是最慷慨的，诸如此类。是的，是的，最慷慨的。
We didn't realize until we were breaking it down and we did a little googling, apparently it was a huge bomb when it first aired. It was not a fan favorite. It is not what it is today, but people did not care for it. The show in general was a huge bomb when people first saw it. This is true. I acquired taste, I suppose. Another one to your point that people did not like at first was Scott's Tots.
大意就是这样。我想大概是：在我这辈子许下的所有空头支票中，这一张是最慷慨的。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。要一本正经地说出这么难的台词可真不容易。
And I loved doing that episode because it was so horrible, but I think they expressed so much about this guy's persona because his heart definitely in the right place and a huge heart, but so wrong. No follow-through. And I think there was a talking head, something to the effect of all the stupid things I've done in my life. This was the most generous or something like that. Yes, yes, the most generous.
你演了那么多精彩的独白。我们每周都在谈论这个，我有时会去看那些被删减的片段，里面也有一些真正的宝藏，但是，詹娜，你最喜欢的是……我有一个最喜欢的，而且我们有一段它的音频片段，我们可以一起听听，就是在迈克尔用乔治·福尔曼烤架烤伤了脚之后，你非常愤怒地解释它是怎么发生的。你太烦躁了。你太防备了。
It was something to that effect. I think it's like of all the empty promises I've made in my life, this one was the most generous. That's it. That's it. That's it. That's it. That's such a hard line to say with a straight face.
为什么我非得解释这个不可，不过好吧，我解释就是了。从头再来。等等，我们得听听。我喜欢在床上吃早餐。我喜欢醒来时闻到培根的香味，告我吧。既然我没有管家，我只能自己动手。所以大多数夜晚睡觉前，我会把六片培根铺在我的乔治·福尔曼烤架上。
You have so many amazing talking heads. We talk about it every week, and I sort of go and look at the deleted scenes, and there's some real gems in there, too, but Jenna, your favorite is... I have a favorite, and we have an audio clip of it so that we can listen to it together, is after Michael burns his foot on the form and grill, and you very angrily explain how it happened. You're so annoyed. You're so defensive.
然后我去睡觉。当我醒来时，我把烤架插上电。然后我接着睡。接着我伴随着滋滋作响的培根香味醒来。太美味了。对我的健康也很好。这是开启一天的完美方式。今天我起床了。
Why do I have to explain this, but I guess here it goes. Again. Wait, we got to hear it. I enjoy having breakfast in bed. I like waking up to the smell of bacon, sue me. And since I don't have a butler, I have to do it myself. So most nights before I go to bed, I will lay six strips of bacon out on my George Form and Grill.
我踩到了烤架上，然后我的脚被夹住了。就是这样。我不明白这有什么难以置信的。我太喜欢你解释完怎么吃培根——每天六片培根——之后的那声长叹了。你说：所以今天。我想其中我最喜欢的部分是他说：“而且对我的健康很好。”顺便带过。
Then I go to sleep. When I wake up, I plug in the grill. I go back to sleep again. Then I wake up to the smell of crackling bacon. It is delicious. It's good for me. It's a perfect way to start the day. Today I got up.
每天早上吃六片培根是多么健康的一件事啊。但如果你剥丝抽茧地分析，这里面有很多东西其实——早上醒来闻到培根的香味确实很美好。我有童年的那种记忆。你周日醒来，爸爸在楼下做煎饼、做培根。这其实真的很——他有他的道理。可能只是现做的培根。不过他可不是像你刚才那样说的。
I stepped onto the grill and I clamped down on my foot. That's it. I don't see what's so hard to believe about that. I love the big sigh after you've explained how you eat bacon, six strips of bacon, every morning. You're like, so today. I think my favorite part of that is when he says, and it's good for me. Just slipping.
问题就在这里。这些对着镜头的独白最棒的地方在于——某种程度上也极其吓人——它写得太好了，以至于你绝不想搞砸。有一种责任感，我知道你们也有同感，当你们拿到一句非常棒的台词、而它就要登场时，你会尽一切努力稍微松一松油门。别为了搞笑而把油门踩到底。真正地放松下来，让它看起来就像是这个家伙脑子里自然延伸的想法，或者是这些女性脑子里自然延伸的想法。而最难的部分就是不要刻意去指点所有这些精彩的笑料，只是让它们感觉像是在闲聊，同时还要忍住不笑。我在拍那段独白时，肯定笑了20次。有一个独白，是什么来着，我几乎快演不下去了。
How good, how healthy eating six strips of bacon in the morning. But there's so much about that if you unpack it like, it actually is really nice to wake up to the smell of bacon. I have that memory from childhood. You wake up on a Sunday, dad's downstairs making the pancakes, making some bacon. It is actually a really, he has a point. Maybe just made bacon. He doesn't say it the way you just did though.
也是类似的情况。太荒谬了。花絮里有一个，你知道的，伊莎贝尔对花絮痴迷不已。
That's the problem. What was so great about those talking heads, and so terrifying in a way, it was so well written that you just didn't want to screw it up. There was an obligation, and I know you guys felt this too, like when you had a really good line and it here comes, you would try to do everything you could to take the pedal off a little bit. Don't floor it for the joke. Really ease off and let it seem like this is just a natural extension of what this guy
她超爱看。所以她会说：“哦，妈妈，你看到第七季了。那里的花絮太棒了。”我就说：“好吧，是的。”但有一个片段，史蒂夫，你根本演不下去，你当时说——我可能会记错。但迈克尔的意思是：我不是个坏人。有时候我开车撞人。
is thinking or what these women are thinking. And that was the hardest part is to not point to all of these fantastic jokes, to just make them feel conversational, and also just to not laugh. I'm sure I laughed 20 times during that, trying to do that talking head. There's one talking head I, what was it, that I could barely get through. And it was the same sort of thing. It was something so ridiculous. There's one in the bloopers, you know, Isabel's obsessed with the bloopers.
就是那个。我刚才想的就是那个。是的，你根本拍不下去。有时候我开车撞人。是的。当我开车撞了梅雷迪思的时候——就像试图为自己的所作所为开脱一样。我不是个坏人，有时候我只是开车撞人。我记得当时在拍那场戏。
She loves them. So she'll be like, oh mom, you're at season seven. There's great bloopers. I'm like, okay, yes. But there was one, Steve, that you could not get through where you said, I'm going to get it wrong. But you're like, Michael's like, I'm not a bad guy. Sometimes I hit people with my car.
我快要说到了，但就是笑得停不下来。每天去上班都知道自己会笑到流泪，这种感觉太美妙了。我在那个片场的每一天，每天至少有一个时刻，我都笑到眼泪直流。我的天，这是多么棒的恩赐。谁能有这样一份工作？所以迈克尔·斯科特这些年来演过很多角色。我们找到了一段被删减的片段，史蒂夫，我想和你分享一下。
That's the one. That's the one I was thinking. Yeah, you couldn't get through it. Sometimes I hit people with my car. Yeah. When I hit Meredith with my car, like trying to absolve myself of having done it. I'm not a bad guy sometimes, I just hit people with my car. And I remember doing it.
我不知道你还记不记得，你知道的，当你听到它时，你就会记起来。那是第三季《罪犯》那一集里的。迈克尔解释了他所有角色、特别是“监狱迈克”的灵感来源。我真的很想让你听听，萨姆，你能放一下吗？当我还是个小孩子的时候，学校里有过一次全校集会，一只巨大的猫头鹰飞出来，发表了一番非常激情的演讲，主题是“支持猫头鹰，拒绝污染”。你知道吗？
I'd be getting close and I couldn't get through it. It's fun going to know you're going to go into work every day and laugh until you cry. Every day I was on that set, at least one point of the day, I was laughing until tears were coming out of my eyes. And I mean, what a gift. Who has a job like that? So Michael Scott had a lot of characters that he would play over the years. And we found a deleted scene, Steve, that I wanted to share with you.
我再也没有污染过环境。就在那一刻，我意识到了以角色的名义说话的力量。当你穿着精心制作的服装，或者用不属于你自己的声音说话时，人们才会听你说话。你能相信这段被删减了吗？这就解释了监狱迈克，大家懂了吧，迈克尔·斯坎，任何时候你穿上戏服、变着嗓子领导会议。你当时想：就是这个？
I don't know if you'll remember it, you know, when you hear it, you'll remember it. But it's from season three in the convict. Michael explains where he got the idea, or I guess inspiration for all of his characters, in particular, prison Mike. I really wanted you to hear it, Sam, can you play it? When I was just a little kid, we had an assembly at school where a giant owl came out and gave a very impassioned speech about giving hoots and not polluting. And you know what?
他们会听我的吗？这就是我最有效的方式，因为你们再也不“支持猫头鹰”了。支持猫头鹰，拒绝污染。显然这跟我撕碎塑料袋有关，你知道的，还有海豚。是的，直到现在。拒绝污染。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔支持猫头鹰。绝对支持。
I never polluted again. It was right then that I realized the power of saying things as a character. People listen to you when you are wearing an elaborate costume or speaking in a voice that is not yours. Can you believe that was deleted? That explains prison Mike, everybody, Michael Skarn, anyone, anytime you let a conference room meeting in a costume with a voice. You thought this is it?
天哪，我的意思是，这就有点像那种模糊的、起雾的记忆，当我听到它时，我有点想起来了。但这样的片段有成千上万个。所有这些东西都有不同的版本，有些片段无论留不留都可能产生不同的效果。是的。但它们都太棒了。而且格雷格，我从来没有为被删减出剧集的任何东西感到后悔。我拥有完全的信心，因为，你知道的，有些人会有占有欲，比如：
They're going to hear me? This is how I am most effective, because you don't give any hoots anymore. You give a hoot, you don't pollute. Clearly this relates back to me tearing apart the plastic, you know, or the dolphin. Yes, even still. You don't pollute. Steve Carell gave a hoot. Sure did.
“好吧，那场戏为什么被删了？”对，对。那里到底发生了什么？他们在结构化整部剧、决定什么该保留、什么虽然很好笑但对剧情无益或者可能是在交代冗长背景故事方面，做得太出色了。但他们只是让观众直接切入核心。他们不必解释一切。但每当我们在重温时偶尔发现一段被删减的场景或类似这样的宝藏片段，我们就会想：哦，原来这就是为什么他会穿着这些服装进来做宏大的展示。全是因为猫头鹰。
Boy, I mean, that's sort of like that vague foggy, as I was hearing it, I kind of recalled. But there are thousands of those. There are different versions of all of this stuff and things that could have made a difference either way. Yeah. But they were so good. And Greg, I never regretted anything that was taken out of the show. I like had complete confidence that because, you know, some people get possessive, like,
当然。那只猫头鹰。你对事情提过意见吗？比如，你很大程度上参与其中了吗？因为我记得有时你在台词围读结束后会留下来，他们会
well, why did that scene go? Right, right. What happened there? They were so good about structuring the show and what needed to be in and what was might have been really funny, but didn't help or might have explained a whole backstory. But they just they let the audience just jump in the middle. They didn't have to like explain everything. But every once in a while as we're doing this rewatch and we find a deleted scene or something
想知道你的想法，而且他们在这方面真的很有合作精神、很开放，对吧？当然是的。而且很多编剧本身也是剧中的演员。这种紧密联系让它感觉不像是在分饰节目的不同板块。再说一次，每个人都觉得自己是协力合作者。编剧也是演员集体的一部分，我认为这很有帮助，因为他们
that's such a nugget, we're like, oh, that's why he would come in these costumes and give a big presentation. It's because of hoot. Sure. The owl. Did you get to give notes on things? Like, were you very much a part of that? Like I would remember sometimes you would stay behind after a table read and they would
更能理解每个人的声线，因为他们就在现场，而且他们听得到。不过，是的，我的意思是，我会发表意见。你会提出自己的点子吗？当然会。是的。你还记得哪个吗？嗯，我确实记得一个具体的，这是后来发生的，那是你和吉姆结婚的时候，他们想让一匹马走过来，我举手说：
want to know your thoughts and things that they were really collaborative and open in that way, right? For sure. Yes. And the fact that so many of the writers were also actors on the show. There was such a great connection that it didn't feel like different facets of the show. Again, everybody just felt like they were all collaborators. And the writers were part of the ensemble, which I think helped because they they understood
我们不能这么做。这太棒了。我的意思是，恕我直言，请千万别这么拍。不只是你。显然，当我们剖析那一集时，我们和格雷格聊过这件事，他说：“史蒂夫叫我别这么拍。兰迪叫我别这么拍。你也叫我别这么拍。”
everyone's voice that much better because they were there and they were hearing it. But yeah, I mean, I I'd weigh in. Would you pitch ideas? Sure. Yeah. Do you remember any? Well, I remember once one specifically, and this is later on, this was when you and Jim were getting married and they wanted to have a horse go over and I raised my hand and said,
简直字面意义上每个人都告诉他别这么拍，他要放弃这个想法太难了。我敢说如果是格雷格来拍，肯定也会很有趣。但那些是罕见的时刻，你会觉得：不，我——是的，我的意思是，这里那里提点小建议。但话说回来，那些编剧太优秀了，对一切都拿捏得那么精准，所以提意见更多是锦上添花，而不是全盘否定。是的。顺便提一句，你知道吗——我们当时不知道，兰迪跟我们分享过这一点——直到拍的前一天，他们还在派拉蒙工作室的大型水池里训练一匹马。
we can't. That's great. I mean, I'll do respect, but please don't do that. It was not just you. Apparently, when we were breaking down that episode, we talked to Greg about it and he was like, Steve told me not to do it. Randy told me not to do it. You told me not to do it.
就像他们已经全系统全员准备就绪，直到前一天还这样。有一匹马正在接受训练。当然有。当你写下一个剧本时，你不会意识到有人会开始动手搭建。是的。我的意思是，事情就是这样开始发生的。
Like literally everyone told him it was so hard for him to let go of that. I'm sure if it was Greg, it would have been funny, definitely. But and those were rare moments when you felt like, no, I yeah, I mean, little notes here and there. But again, those writers were so good and so on point about everything that it was more in addition to as opposed to negating. Yeah. Side note, did you know, we didn't know this, Randy shared this with us that up until like
所以当你写下：“哦，所以现在我们要去树林里了。”然后一个月后，你要开一个半小时的车去洛杉矶森林里拍几场戏。我就想：我为什么会写出这么糟糕的主意？森林里是夜里。荒郊野岭。冻得要死。太糟糕了。
right like the day before, they had a horse, they were training in a big water pool at Paramount Studios. Like they were all systems go like right up until like the day before. There was a horse being trained. Of course there was. You don't realize when you write something, somebody starts to build it. Yeah. I mean, it starts to happen.
太糟糕了。他掉进小溪里。什么？我为什么会写这个？所以我们聊过这部剧是如何慢热才找到观众的。感觉就像我们在做一个小型的戏剧制作，却没有人看。但后来有一天它迎来了转折点，每个人都知道这部剧了，而且我们开始遇到粉丝。
So when you say, oh, so now we're going to be out in the woods. And then a month later, you're driving an hour and a half up into the Los Angeles Forest to shoot a few scenes. Like, why did I write this terrible idea? It's nighttime in the forest. The middle of nowhere. Freezing. Terrible.
詹娜，你还记得我们在一个颁奖典礼上，劳拉·邓恩走过来对我们说：“停下，我必须跟你聊聊。”我们当时想：什么？她说：“我太爱你们的剧了。”我当时想：这可是劳拉·邓恩。天哪。但是对你来说，史蒂夫，有没有谁像这样让你感到惊讶、让你始料未及，结果竟然是这部剧的粉丝？
Terrible. He falls in a creek. What? Why did I write it? So we've talked how the show was slow to find an audience. It was sort of like we were doing a little theater production and no one's seeing it. But then one day it turned to corner and everybody knew the show and we had people coming up to us.
劳拉·邓恩。完全一样。我在后来某个地方遇到了她。我和她一起做宣传活动。我甚至不知道你和她有过偶遇，因为她显然是个粉丝，因为她对聊起这部剧感到非常兴奋，她对我也说了同样的话。她太爱这部剧了。而且每当有人喜欢你参与的项目时，那种感觉总是美好的，尤其是特别美好的。
Jenna, do you remember we're at an award show and Laura Dern was like, stop, I have to talk to you. And we're like, what? She was like, I love your show. And I was like, this is Laura Dern. Oh my gosh. But was there anyone like that for you, Steve, that sort of surprised you and caught you off guard that was a fan of the show?
珍娜，还记得我们在一个颁奖典礼上，劳拉·邓恩突然说，等等，我得跟你聊聊。我们当时想，什么？她说，我太喜欢你们的节目了。当时我就想，这可是劳拉·邓恩。天哪。史蒂夫，对你来说有没有谁也是这样，让你感到意外和措手不及，居然也是节目的粉丝呢？
Laura Dern. Same thing. I met her somewhere down the road. I was doing a promotional thing with her. And I wasn't even aware of your encounter with her because she was clearly a fan because she was very excited to talk about the show and she said the same thing to me. She loved it. And it's nice when anyone likes something that you're a part of and especially nice
劳拉·邓恩。完全一样。后来我在某个地方遇到了她。当时我和她一起做宣传活动。我甚至不知道你和她有过那次接触，因为她显然是粉丝，她对谈论这个节目感到非常兴奋，她也对我说了一样的话。她很喜欢。当任何人喜欢你参与的作品时，这都是件美好的事，尤其是这样更是如此
when somebody that you respect like that and has sort of a critical eye for things likes your show. So yeah, it was really nice. It was nice hearing any of it because you're right, early on it felt like we were in a vacuum and is any, let alone appreciating, is anyone watching it, is anyone paying any sort of attention and the only part of it that mattered to me was the continuation of the show. I wanted to have enough people watch it so they kept letting us do it because I didn't
当一个你这样尊敬、对事物有着挑剔眼光的人喜欢你的节目时。所以，是的，真的很棒。听到这些感觉真好，因为你说得对，早期感觉我们就像在一个真空里，有没有人，更不用说欣赏了，有没有人在看，有没有人哪怕有一点点关注，而对我来说唯一重要的部分就是节目的延续。我希望有足够多的人看它，这样他们就会一直让我们拍下去，因为我并不
really care about the acclaim or like we knew that we liked it and we were having fun with it and I think we all felt like it was special in that moment and that's what mattered to me. But yeah, yeah, it was a slower turn. I remember that time early on because we, a few of us had gotten on Myspace and we were able to interact with the like 17 people who were watching our show in the beginning and they were such fans and they so got it and they so appreciated it and that really like kind of, that just felt so good, you know?
真的在乎赞誉，或者说我们知道我们喜欢它，而且我们拍得很开心，我想我们当时都觉得它是特别的，这对我来说才是最重要的。但是，是的，这是一个缓慢的转折。我还记得早期的那个时候，因为我们，我们中的几个人上了MySpace，我们能够和刚开始看我们节目的那大约17个人互动，他们是那么好的粉丝，他们是那么懂，那么欣赏，这真的让人，感觉太棒了，你知道吗？
Because when you make a television show, you don't hear the people laugh when they watch it and you don't know how it's being received or a movie or whatever, I guess, unless you sneak in the theater but you can't like go sneak in people's living rooms while they watch it. So I always loved when someone told us that they loved it, especially a fellow artist and they were excited too because the show was different with the documentary style and the looking at the camera. Would you look into the camera after you got jobs on the office?
因为当你制作一部电视剧时，你听不到人们观看时的笑声，你也不知道它反响如何，电影或其他什么，我想，除非你溜进影院，但你不能像那样溜进人们看电视的客厅里。所以我总是喜欢有人告诉我们他们很喜欢，尤其是同行为艺术家，他们也很兴奋，因为这部剧很与众不同，有纪录片风格和直视镜头。你在《办公室》里得到工作之后，也会看镜头吗？
I have never had a job where I didn't look into the camera at some point. Same. Same. I can't not make the camera a character now. It's so, such a habit. At least once. Yeah. I'm sure on Foxcatcher, I like looked into the camera and went, nope, you cannot comment
我从来没有做过一份工作是在某些时候不看镜头的。我也是。我也是。我现在做不到不把镜头当成一个角色了。这太，太成习惯了。至少一次。是的。我敢肯定在《狐狸猎手》里，我看着镜头说，不，你不能对你刚刚做的事情发表评论，
on what you just did because that's not this show. Yeah. Same for me. I actually had a director say, uh, Angela, you just looked right down the barrel. I was like, oh, I'm sorry. I looked to the left or right. It was such a fun, uh, kind of discipline. Know who was really good at that right off the bat was Amy Adams.
因为这不是那个节目。是的。我也是。我其实有个导演说过，呃，安吉拉，你刚刚直视了镜头。我说，哦，对不起。我看了左边或右边。这真是一种有趣，呃，类似于纪律的东西。知道谁一开始就很擅长这个的人是艾米·亚当斯。
I'll never forget because it was kind of a learned strength, I think, on the show to figure out the right way to play the camera to, to invite the camera in and to make it feel like these people aren't used to the cameras. So you couldn't be too savvy, especially at first. You couldn't, you couldn't play it too well. You, you needed to have an awareness of it without like having an over-awareness of it. Yes. Um, but I remember when Amy Adams came in to do purse girl, was that it?
我永远不会忘记，因为我觉得这是在这部剧里学到的一种强项，弄清楚如何面对镜头的正确方式，去，去邀请镜头进来，并让人觉得这些人并不习惯面对镜头。所以你不能表现得太精明，尤其是一开始。你不能，你不能演得太好。你，你需要对它有意识，但又不能过度有意识。是的。嗯，但是我还记得艾米·亚当斯来客串“包包女孩”的时候，是那个吗？
Hot girl. Hot girl. She was selling the purse. Selling the purse. Yeah. And I remember she just had like this, she was right up to speed with everybody else in terms of how to play the camera, like it's eavesdropping. And I don't know how I should react to it.
辣妹。辣妹。她在卖包。卖包。是的。我记得她当时就像这样，她在如何面对镜头方面和大家一样上手很快，就像是在偷听。而且我不知道自己该做何反应。
And that sort of discomfort built in that we had learned how to do. So she was really good at that. And that was such an interesting, and we'll never, we'll never get to do something like that again. It was a really interesting acting exercise to be, you know, you're doing, you're in your character and your character is also being watched. So there was like another layer of something going on with all of these characters, which is kind of cool.
还有我们已经学会的那种与生俱来的不适感。所以她真的很擅长那个。那真是一个有趣的，而且我们永远，永远不会再有机会做那样的事情了。这是一种非常有趣的表演练习，你知道的，你在演你的角色，而你的角色同时也在被注视着。所以所有这些角色身上都还有另一层东西在发生，这挺酷的。
You mentioned Amy Adams, one of my favorite guest stars that we had in terms of chemistry with you was Tim Meadows. You guys doing the baby back ribs. That also, that episode has one of my favorite lines in it, which is, Gould is dead because Jan is no longer Jan Levinson Gould. Yeah. And she's like, no, Michael, we got, we're separated, we're divorced, Gould didn't die. Because if, as if she would drop the Gould from her name if he died, right, as a widow.
你提到了艾米·亚当斯，就你俩之间的化学反应而言，我们最喜欢的客串明星之一就是蒂姆·梅多斯。你们俩吃烤肋排的那段。还有那一集里我最喜欢的台词之一，那就是，古尔德死了，因为简不再是简·莱文森·古尔德了。是的。然后她说，不，迈克尔，我们，我们分居了，我们离婚了，古尔德没死。因为就好像如果他死了，她就会从名字里去掉古尔德一样，对吧，作为一个未亡人。
Yeah. Amazing. But yeah, I love you guys. I don't know how you got through all the rib eating and singing and comedy from that episode. I've known Tim for a long time too. And we did a second city show that went to Washington DC at the Kennedy Center with Nancy. We went as this, this group one summer and spent, I don't know, three, three weeks at
太棒了。但是，是的，我太喜欢你们了。我不知道你们是怎么熬过那一集里所有的吃肋排、唱歌和喜剧表演的。我和蒂姆认识很久了。我们和南希一起做过一个去华盛顿特区肯尼迪中心的第二城喜剧团演出。那个夏天我们作为这个，这个团体去了，呆了，我不知道，三个，三周在
the Kennedy Center doing a second city show. And I had known him from second city as well, you know, earlier on stage. And he is so, I think he's one of those, one of those people that is always great. He's never not great, you know, sometimes people like that are under the radar. And then they pop out and you say, oh my gosh, like, they're incredible. And yeah, he's, I think, one of the best and he's a great improviser. And he's so, he's so effortless. He just doesn't look like he's ever breaking a sweat and he's hilarious.
肯尼迪中心做第二城喜剧团的演出。而且我以前在舞台上更早的时候就从第二城认识他了，你知道的。而且他非常，我觉得他是那种，那种总是表现出色的人。他从来没有表现不佳的时候，你知道的，有时这样的人会默默无闻。然后他们突然大放异彩，你会说，哦天哪，天哪，他们太不可思议了。而且，是的，我认为他是最棒的人之一，他是一个出色的即兴演员。而且他太，太毫不费力了。他看起来好像从来没有流过汗，而且他太搞笑了。
Oh, yeah, I'm a big fan. He's a great guy. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we have some more questions from the fans. Okie doke. All right, we're back. And while we were on break, before we get to fan questions, Steve, I remembered this cold open that we did that led into a talking head that was one sentence from you.
哦，是的，我是他的超级粉丝。他是个好人。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，我们还有来自粉丝的更多问题。好的。好了，我们回来了。在我们休息期间，在回答粉丝问题之前，史蒂夫，我想起了我们做过的一个冷开场，它引出了一个由你说的只有一句话的单人独白。
When I rewatched it, I laughed so hard, I had tears streaming down my face. What? Do you remember the cold open that we did where we're all trying to take the Christmas photo? Yeah. Yes. Yeah. And we're trying to jump on three, three, two, one, one, two, three.
当我重温它时，我笑得太厉害了，眼泪顺着脸颊流了下来。什么？你还记得我们拍的那个大家都试图拍圣诞照片的冷开场吗？对。是的。对。然后我们在三的时候跳，三，二，一，一，二，三。
Yeah. This whole thing. Dwight's like, Phyllis didn't jump, Angela didn't jump. Yes. And it's so long, this cold open. And then it cuts to a talking head of Michael and Michael says, we never got it. You know what? That cold open is a perfect demonstration of us as an ensemble, I think.
对。整个过程。德怀特说，菲利斯没跳，安吉拉没跳。是的。而且这个冷开场好长。然后切到一个迈克尔的单人独白，迈克尔说，我们没拍成。你知道吗？那个冷开场完美地展现了我们作为集体演员阵容的状态，我觉得。
Yeah. Because to make it look as bad as it did took some effort. Like we had to be completely in sync to be that out of sync. And everyone jumping at different times. Yeah. And Michael getting frustrated like a dad would like, come on, come on, guys. I think that's a perfect example of how in sync we were as a cast because we all got what that thing was and how many people needed to be going at one time, but we didn't talk
对。因为要把它拍得那么糟是需要下一番功夫的。就像我们必须完全合拍，才能表现得那么不合拍。每个人都在不同的时间跳。是的。然后迈克尔像个爸爸一样感到沮丧，就像，拜托，拜托，伙计们。我认为这完美地证明了我们作为演员阵容是多么合拍，因为我们都明白那是个什么东西，以及需要在同一时间进行多少人，但我们没有讨论
about it. No. We didn't discuss like, well, on the count of three, you two are going to go. And then we just, as a group, we just felt that and not to give ourselves too big a pat on the back, but I think I've watched that since and thought the same thing. Like that's, there was something, something cool happening there. That was one of my favorite group cold opens for that reason. I know.
过。没有。我们没有讨论过，嗯，数到三，你们两个要上。然后我们只是作为一个团队，纯粹靠感觉，并不是为了自我标榜，但我之后看过那个片段，也有过同感。就像那里正在发生一些，一些很酷的事情。正因如此，那是我最喜欢的集体冷开场之一。我知道。
Well, let's get into these fan questions. Okay. Catherine G and Kristi R both asked, if you had to choose a different character to play on the office besides Michael, is there one you'd like to be? Wow. I can't imagine anyone but the people who played their parts. Right off the top of my head, I think Dwight is a very fun role to play. But I would have been terrible.
好吧，让我们进入这些粉丝提问吧。好的。凯瑟琳·G和克里斯蒂·R都问，如果你必须在《办公室》里选择扮演迈克尔以外的另一个角色，有没有哪个是你愿意演的？哇。除了那些扮演各自角色的演员之外，我无法想象任何人。一想到这儿，我觉得德怀特是一个非常有趣的表演角色。但我肯定演得很烂。
I mean, rain was perfect for that part. So no, I never like, I never imagined myself in another part. It was, it was just as it should have been. Lauren D asked, what trend or big pop culture moment that's happened since 2011? Do you think Michael would have gotten obsessed about? For example, Lauren thinks Michael would have been all over the ice bucket challenge. Oh, yeah. I think she's 14.
我的意思是，雷恩对那个角色来说太完美了。所以不，我从来没有，我从来没有想象过自己去演另一个角色。它就是，它本来就该是那个样子的。劳伦·D问，你认为2011年以来发生的哪个流行文化趋势或重大时刻会让迈克尔着迷？例如，劳伦认为迈克尔一定会疯狂参与冰桶挑战。哦，是的。我想她是14岁。
I think she's absolutely right. So much ice water. Oh, and would have done something wrong. Someone might have ended up in the hospital. Probably Meredith. Dwight would have overdone it too. Yes. Yeah.
我想她绝对猜对了。那么多冰水。哦，而且肯定会搞出什么差错。最后可能会有人送进医院。可能是梅雷迪斯。德怀特也会做得过头。对。是的。
It would have gone south somehow. It would have gone wrong. We say that we think that Michael probably would have made us all learn TikTok dances. Oh, sure. So many TikTok dances. Yeah. So the internet wasn't as certainly as much of a thing as social media really was. We had flip phones when we started the show, then we got blackberries and then at the end
不知怎么地事情就会往糟糕的方向发展。事情肯定会出岔子。我们说我们觉得迈克尔可能会让我们所有人去学TikTok舞蹈。哦，当然。有那么多的TikTok舞蹈。是的。所以当时互联网肯定不像现在这样，社交媒体也没有真正成为那么大的一回事。我们刚开始拍这部剧时用的是翻盖手机，后来有了黑莓手机，最后
we had iPhones. Yeah. Yeah. A lot changed. Yeah. There are tons of things that Michael would have glommed on to in the worst possible way. Beth M writes in and says, what is the most common Michael line that people quote back
我们用上了iPhone。是的。是的。变化很大。是的。有无数的事情是迈克尔会以最糟糕的方式疯狂跟风的。贝丝·M来信写道，人们最常向你引用的迈克尔的台词是什么？
to you? What do you think it is? Yeah, Beth. That's what she said. Is there one other than that? That's the one I hear. And sometimes, I don't know, do people ever stop you and say, oh, could you talk to, could you do a shout out into my phone and I'm happy to do it.
你觉得会是什么？是的，贝丝。那是她说的。除了那个还有别的吗？我总听到这句。有时，我不知道，人们有没有拦住你并说，哦，你能对着我的手机说句话吗，我非常乐意效劳。
But when they say, can you say that, I just, I don't, I can't. It can be taken out of context. Out of context. Please don't make Steve say that's what she said if you see him at the airport. Do you ever, that's what she said in your life, do you ever find, never? No. Really? I don't do it.
但当他们说，你能说那句话吗，我只是，我不会，我不能。这可能会被断章取义。断章取义。如果你在机场看到史蒂夫，请不要让他说那是她说的。你在生活中会说，那是她说的吗，你有没有发现，从来没有？不。真的吗？我不用。
I do throw them out. Jenna. I do. Yeah. Well, you can. Gosh, it's going to be so weird when we give you your parting gift. It's a t-shirt that says that's what she said. Well, I do wear that all the time.
我会说出口的。珍娜。我会的。是的。好吧，你可以的。天哪，当我们送你离别礼物时，气氛一定会变得好奇怪。那是一件印有“那是她说的”的T恤。好吧，我确实经常穿那件衣服。
And on the back it says, I'm fantastic. Same brain. We really liked this question because we both come from a long line of teachers. Someone wanted to know if you remember a favorite teacher. There was one in particular, a guy named Mr. Blackman, my second grade teacher. And he's the one who got me interested in acting in the first play. We were doing like a pilgrims meet the Native Americans thing. It was a long time ago.
背面印着，我很棒。心有灵犀。我们非常喜欢这个问题，因为我们俩都出身于教师世家。有人想知道你是否还记得某个最喜欢的老师。有一个特别的人，一个叫布莱克曼先生的人，我的二年级老师。就是他让我对在第一部戏剧中表演产生了兴趣。我们当时在做类似于“清教徒遇见美洲原住民”的情景剧。那是很久以前的事了。
So a lot was being glossed over for sure. But what I remember is we were rowing canoes and it was all mime. You know, we were sitting in little chairs in the classroom. It wasn't a big play. It was just like an in-class thing. And I started rowing the canoe, my mime rowing. And then I changed my hands with the oar and rode on the other side. I'll never forget it.
所以很多事情肯定都被一笔带过了。但我记得的是我们在划独木舟，全部都是哑剧。你知道，我们坐在教室的小椅子上。那不是一出大戏，只是类似于课堂上的一个小活动。我开始划独木舟，我的哑剧划船。然后我换了拿桨的手，在另一边划。我永远不会忘记。
He singled me out. It's the first time I'd ever been singled out in any way. And he gave me a pat on the back and said, notice how Steve rode on both sides of the canoe so we wouldn't go in a circle. And he kept the canoe straight, you know, in this mime, you know, miming the canoe. And something about that really struck me. And I thought, and apart from that, he was just the most lovely guy and really kind to all the kids and everyone.
他把我挑了出来。这是我生平第一次以任何方式被挑出来。他拍了拍我的背说，注意史蒂夫是如何在独木舟的两边划船的，这样我们才不会转圈。而且他让独木舟保持笔直，你知道的，在这个哑剧里，你知道，假装划独木舟。不知何故，那件事深深地触动了我。我想，除此之外，他简直是最可爱的人，对所有的孩子和每个人都真的很好。
It was fun. It was really just a fun class. And he did that for all the kids, too. He made them feel special about whatever talent they had, whether it was art or music or anything. He really embraced, you know, everyone's abilities, you know, as little as they were in that moment as a second grader. But I'll never forget it. Like being seen.
这很有趣。这真的只是一个有趣的班级。而且他对所有的孩子也都这样。无论他们有什么天赋，不管是艺术、音乐还是别的什么，他都让他们觉得自己很特别。他真的包容了，你知道的，每个人当时作为二年级学生所拥有的微不足道的能力。但我永远不会忘记它。就像被看见了一样。
Yeah. You're not seen. Yeah. And it was that was special, something sort of clicked like, oh, that felt good. And so I guess I owe it all to him. You know, Steve, I love that story because I have a similar story. I took a summer school acting class and we had to do pantomime. We had to mime things.
对。你没有被看见。对。那是很特别的，某种感觉就像，哦，这种感觉真好。所以我想我这一切都要归功于他。你知道，史蒂夫，我很喜欢这个故事，因为我有一个类似的经历。我上过一个暑期表演课，我们必须做哑剧。我们必须模仿各种东西。
And my assignment was to go over to the refrigerator and get out some milk, important a glass and drink it. And so I did it. And afterwards, the teacher said, did everyone notice how Jenna shut the refrigerator with her foot? Oh, yeah. It's exactly. And I was like, wait, I might be good at this because I didn't think it just I maybe I have
我的作业是走到冰箱前拿点牛奶，倒进杯子里喝了。所以我照做了。然后，老师说，大家注意到珍娜是怎么用脚关上冰箱的吗？哦，对。就是这样。然后我想，等等，我可能挺擅长这个的，因为我没多想，这只是，也许我
a little thing. Right. Exactly. You know, and then it just makes you feel like I might be good at this or it might be something. Yeah. You know, it might be something that I'm actually, yeah, capable of. That's so fun.
有点这方面的天赋。对。没错。你知道，然后它就会让你觉得我可能挺擅长这个的，或者这可能是个什么。是的。你知道，这可能是我真的，是的，能够胜任的事情。太有趣了。
And it's not even like, look at me like, no, it's just a sense of a set like the one of the first senses of pride that you ever feel that you accomplish something completely on your own, not your parents and nothing that you are instructed to do. It's just something that you did naturally. And to have somebody notice it felt really good. And that's a great teacher in my mind. Somebody who can pick up on those things. Yeah.
这甚至不像是在说，快看我，不，这只是一种成就感，就像你感受到的最早的自豪感之一，你完全靠自己完成了一件事，不是父母，也不是别人指令你去做什么。这只是你自然而然做的事。而能让别人注意到它，感觉真的很好。在我看来，这就是一个好老师。一个能捕捉到这些细节的人。是的。
Okay. I love this question. Here it is. Are there any foods you don't eat anymore because of so many takes you had to do with that certain food? It can be on the office or any other job. I know mine right away. It's that cake that we had to eat, the ice cream cake for Meredith's birthday.
好的。我很喜欢这个问题。是这样的。有没有什么食物是你现在再也不吃了，因为为了拍那个特定的食物你拍了太多次？可以是在《办公室》里，也可以是在任何其他工作中。我一下子就能想到我的那个。就是我们不得不吃的那个蛋糕，为梅雷迪斯生日准备的冰淇淋蛋糕。
The mint chocolate chip. Was it the Alliance? We started filming at 7.30 in the morning and we were given a slice of cake. And you know, this is a rookie move on my part. I took a plate with a big piece of cake and I took a huge bite in that first take. And by the end my fork was shaking as it got close to my mouth because I was like, I can't eat it anymore. Anyway, I was asking you that, but clearly I have a visceral, like I can't eat ice cream
薄荷巧克力豆味的。是那个吗？我们早上7点半开始拍摄，然后发给我们一块蛋糕。你知道，这是我犯的一个新手错误。我拿了一个装有一大块蛋糕的盘子，在第一条里就咬了一大口。到最后，当叉子靠近我的嘴时，它都在颤抖，因为我想，我实在吃不下去了。总之，我本来是在问你这个，但显然我有了一种本能的反应，比如我再也吃不下冰淇淋
cake anymore. That did it. That did you in. Yeah. It's so gross to me. I learned early on to nibble. Yeah. Not like if that first take, try not to take a big bite because then you have to match
蛋糕了。那次可把你害惨了。那就是罪魁祸首。是的。我觉得太恶心了。我早早就学会了要小口小口地吃。是的。如果是第一条，尽量不要咬一大口，因为接下来的一整天你都得保持连戏。
it for the rest of the day. Every time. Yeah. Or I'm not hungry today. You know, my character's not hungry. But Michael would eat some pretty crazy stuff. Nothing that turned my stomach, nothing to the point where I can't eat it anymore. I did a bit on The Daily Show where I was supposed to be eating Crisco.
每一次。是的。或者我今天不饿。你知道的，我的角色不饿。但迈克尔会吃一些相当疯狂的东西。没有什么让我反胃的，没有到那种我再也吃不下的地步。我在《每日秀》里有一个小品，我本该吃Crisco起酥油的。
I was doing, it was some health food segment and I said, well, this is all vegetable based. And I was like at the desk with John. And so I take a big spoonful of Crisco. For real? Well, they wanted to mock it up and just put like vanilla frosting in because no one would know and I could play it like it's Crisco. But I said, no, leave Crisco in because that's going to be funnier for John to watch me eat Crisco because the expression on his face was pretty horrifying and I didn't practice
我在做，这是一个健康食品环节，我说，这全都是植物成分的。我当时和约翰坐在桌子旁。然后我舀了一大勺Crisco。真的吗？嗯，他们本来想作假，只放点香草糖霜，因为没人会知道，我可以假装它是Crisco。但我说，不，把Crisco留在那里，因为让约翰看着我吃Crisco会更有趣，因为他脸上的表情非常吓人，而且我没有排练过
it. So I didn't know what I was getting myself into. And so on camera, basically live, you know, that show is live to tape, but it was really bad. Not, I could, I mean, the two of us had a hard time getting through the rest of that segment because he knew, he knew, he knew I was in distress. So not that I would sit around eating Crisco, but that kind of, that was a hard one. Here's a good question.
。所以我不知道自己将会面临什么。所以在镜头前基本上是直播，你知道，那个节目是录播，但真的很糟糕。不是，我的意思是，我们俩很难熬过那个环节剩下的部分，因为他知道，他知道，他知道我很痛苦。所以倒不是说我会坐着吃Crisco，但那个确实挺难的。这是一个好问题。
Do you have a Toby in your life? Someone who just enrages you, this was one of our favorite questions sent in. Because we're like, we're sure Steve doesn't have a Toby face, but yeah. Someone who just, really for no reason, you just hate, just abject hatred. No, I don't, but that, that's, that's one of my favorite character dynamics of the time that I spent on the office. And it evolved from, I don't exactly, I know it's been discussed as to, and I think the writers could sort of pinpoint clearly.
你的生活中有一个托比吗？那种让你怒火中烧的人，这是我们收到的最喜欢的问题之一。因为我们想，我们确信史蒂夫没有托比脸，但是，是的。那种毫无理由地，你就是讨厌的人，纯粹的痛恨。不，我没有，但那，那是，我在《办公室》度过的时光里我最喜欢的角色动态之一。而且它是演变而来的，我不太确凿，我知道大家一直在讨论，我想编剧们也能明确指出原因。
But I think one day I just decided, I just got really mad at him and like disgusted by him for no reason. And we just kind of stayed with it. People lost it. They would lose it at a table read when you would snap at Toby. We didn't interview with Paul and he said he remembers the moment. Oh, he does? It was during the alliance when he has to come in the office and sign Meredith's birthday
但我认为有一天我只是决定，我突然对他非常生气，并且毫无理由地对感到他厌恶。然后我们就顺着这种感觉演下去了。大家笑疯了。每当你在片场厉声斥责托比时，他们在剧本围读时都会笑翻天。我们采访过保罗，他说他记得那个时刻。哦，真的是吗？那是是在《同盟》那一集里，他不得不走进办公室在梅雷迪斯的生日
card. And apparently it just took him a long time to write. And you turned on him and you told him, you said, I don't know what it is, Paul, but I hate you for how long it's taken you to write this card. And you guys laughed so hard about it. And you met like me as Michael. Like Michael is so irritated with you right now and that that was like everyone else just signed their name, but he started to write something.
卡片上签字。显然他写了很久。然后你转过身冲着他说，你说道，我不知道为什么，保罗，但我恨你写这张卡片花了这么长时间。你们俩为此笑得前仰后合。你的意思是作为迈克尔的我？就像迈克尔现在对你太恼火了，而且就像其他人都在卡片上签了名字，但他却开始写点什么。
Yeah. It was, I love the fact that it was never discussed to as to why and the specifics of it. Yeah. And people have asked me that too. Well, why? Why does Michael hate Toby so much? And I think, well, I think it's like the end when our characters say goodbye to each other.
是的。我喜欢这样一个事实，即从没有讨论过原因以及其中的具体细节。是的。人们也这样问过我。嗯，为什么？为什么迈克尔那么讨厌托比？我想，嗯，我觉得就像最后当我们的角色互相告别时。
I'll never talk about exactly what was said because that's, that's like our thing. And it's more fun too to leave those things as sort of a mystery. Like, well, why really? Because I built in Michael's head like all of the reasons, but it's better that you don't know that it just kind of sits there. That's how I feel about the teapot letter, right? Everyone wants to know what's in the teapot letter. And the thing is, is that what's in the teapot letter is what you need to be in the teapot
我永远不会谈论具体说了什么，因为那是，那是我们之间的秘密。而且把那些事情留作某种谜题也会更有趣。就像，好吧，到底为什么？因为我在迈克尔的脑海里构建了所有的原因，但你不知道反而更好，就让它静静地呆在那里。对于茶壶信，我也是这种感觉，对吧？每个人都想知道茶壶信里写了什么。但关键在于，茶壶信里写的东西就是需要写进茶壶
letter. Yeah. There's what I needed to be in the teapot letter. There's the thing that Pam needs, but like it has to be the most wonderful romantic thing and you can't write it like you can't tell people what was in it. It'll just be a let down. It will. It can't live up to it, right?
信里的东西。是的。那是需要写进茶壶信里的内容。那是潘需要的，但它必须是最美妙浪漫的东西，而且你不能写成，你不能告诉大家里面到底写了什么。那只会让人失望。确实会。它无法承载那种期待，对吧？
So it's like, I know what it said completely, but it's better if you write it yourself as an audience member. I think the writers in general felt that way about the show and I think Greg was very savvy about that, that you don't have to tell the whole story and just let people come to it. And I think that's partly why people have liked the show over the years. It doesn't spell everything out about these characters or about these relationships. You kind of acquire a knowledge over time and it becomes more ingrained that way. This is sort of off the subject, but you're talking about the teapot letter and I've thought
所以就像，我很清楚上面写了什么，但作为观众，你自己来写会更好。我想编剧们对这部剧总是有这种感觉，而且我认为格雷格在这方面非常精明，你不需要把整个故事都讲完，只需让观众自己去体会。我想这也是人们多年来一直喜欢这部剧的部分原因。它没有把关于这些角色或这些关系的每一件事都明说出来。随着时间的推移，你逐渐了解了它们，这种羁绊也就这样变得更加深入。这有点题外话了，但你刚才在说茶壶信，自从我离开这部剧以来，我已经想过这件事很多很多次了，那就是你和约翰，在我看来，你和约翰是这部剧的基石。就像如果没有你们两个角色，我觉得这部剧早就分崩离析了，因为里面有太多的疯狂和荒诞，而你们俩在这部剧里既能表现得极其搞笑和真实，同时又都是如此脚踏实地的角色。但事实上，每个人都可以从你们身上借力，你们非常脚踏实地、充满爱意且有趣的感情以及这种感情是如何成长的，对我来说，这就是这部剧的核心。我一直都是这么觉得的，而且你们俩都是那么优秀的演员
about this many, many times since I left the show that you and John, in my opinion, you and John were the rock of that show. Like if not for your two characters, I feel like that show would have imploded because there was so much craziness going on and so much wackiness and you were both such grounded characters on that show while simultaneously being incredibly funny and real. But the fact that everyone could bounce off of you and your very grounded, loving and interesting relationship and how that grew, to me, that was the nucleus of the show. I've always felt that way and the way that you guys and you're both such good actors
。就像我们在很多方面都太幸运了，无论是这部剧的选角，还是剧本。当然，我把这一切归功于你们，还有格雷格把这群人以恰到好处的化学反应聚集在一起。我不知道我是否曾专门对你这么说过，但我一直都是这样觉得的。史蒂夫，谢谢你。我记得当我们准备拍摄试播集时，斯蒂芬和里奇来探班，
too. It's like we were so fortunate on so many fronts in terms of the casting of this show, in terms of the writing. I attribute it to you guys, obviously, and to Greg for putting this group of people together in just the right sort of alchemy. I don't know if I've ever specifically told you that, but I've always felt that way. Steve, thank you. I remember when we got ready to shoot the pilot, Steven and Ricky came to visit and
我们和他们开了一整天的会，斯蒂芬告诉我和约翰，永远不要忘记你们两个是这部剧的心脏。我记得当时就像在《头号威胁》里一样，我忍不住咽了一口口水。我想，我其实不知道那是什么意思。这对我来说有点吓人。我原本只想继续扮演我那种墙花似的角色，潘就只是坐在桌子后面，送上几道目光，我其实挺喜欢那个戏份的。但随着时间的推移，我明白了这番话的意思，这有点像你刚才说的，
we had this one day meeting with them and Steven told John and I, never forget you two are the heart of the show. I remember it was like in Threat Level Midnight, I was like, gulp, gulp. I thought, I don't really know what that means. That's sort of scary to me. I was sort of hoping to kind of keep with my whole like wallflower thing where Pam just kind of sits at the desk and gives a couple of stares, really liking that lane. But over time, I understood what he meant and it's kind of what you're saying, which
也就是，我们不会总是把镜头对准你们，甚至可能不会经常这么做。但在一个宏大的故事弧光中，在一个漫长的时间跨度里，这是一件非常重要的事情。所以只要确保你始终珍视它。确保你知道你要对得起这份珍视。我很高兴我们做到了。我很高兴吉姆和潘最终走到了一起并维持下去了，他们没有搞那种把你们分开然后再凑到一起、分分合合、破镜重圆的戏码。如果我们在接受采访时有人对珍娜说，嗯，我觉得吉姆和潘现在还在一起，我就会对吉姆和潘产生极强的保护欲，我会想，你怎么敢这么说？他们当然还在一起。德怀特和安吉拉也是，迈克尔和霍莉也是。一边去吧。哦，你知道吗？我得跟你说个事。不。
is like, we're not going to go to you all the time or maybe even very often. But over a large arc, over a large period of time, this is a really important thing. And so just make sure you always honor it. Make sure that you know that you honor that. And I'm so glad we did. I'm so glad Jim and Pam made it and work and they didn't do that thing where they pull you apart and put you back together and put you back together and make up makeup. And I get really defensive of Jim and Pam if like we're doing an interview and someone's
噢天哪。抱歉。关于迈克尔和霍莉。不。这很糟糕。这真的很糟糕。哦，我不想深入讨论了。我们刚刚看了那个场景，而且，我觉得我正在重新发现其中的许多
like to Jenna, so I think Jim and Pam are still together. I'm like, how dare you? Of course they're still together. And so are Dwight and Angela and so are Michael and Holly. Get out of here. Oh, you know what? I need to tell you about that. No.
场景，因为自从它播出以来我们已经很久没看过这部剧了，你知道的，其中的很多剧集。但当你和艾米·瑞安演那一幕时，你，谁，哈，就像那个时刻。它基本上是在说，我爱你，就像，哟，醒醒吧，真是疯了，你，简直是，我当时都要流泪了。是的。我甚至把这放给珍娜看。我说，你得看看这个场景。他们只是在说你，但它非常有力量。
Oh dear. Sorry. About Michael and Holly. No. It is bad. It is bad. Oh, I don't want to get into it. We just watched the scene and it's, you know, I feel like I'm rediscovering so many of these
是的。艾米·瑞安相当不错。是的，她还行。她挺好的。我的意思是，我想我们能请她来演这部剧真是太幸运了。我想她为自己取得了很不错的成就。是的。太棒了。
scenes because we haven't seen the show since it aired, you know, a lot of these episodes. But when you and Amy Ryan do that, you are, who, ha, like that moment. And it says basically, I love you, like, yo, wake it's mad, you are, it's like, I was like tearing up. Yeah. I would like played it for Jenna. I was like, you got to watch the scene. They're just saying you are, but it's like so powerful.
我们确实刚刚看完了所有这些剧集。我们看了向霍莉求婚的片段，以及唱着告别歌的片段，你知道的，所有针对不同人的个别告别。对你来说，最后这几周真是太残酷了。我的意思是，我们，我们是不是一直在哭？我们是怎么挺过来的？我不知道。我，你知道的，我可以这样看待它，我，我不知道。
Yeah. Amy Ryan's pretty good. Yeah, she's okay. She was fine. I mean, I guess we were lucky to get her in the show. She did pretty well for herself, I think. Yeah. Fantastic.
我不想过分解读，但它，它确实很难，因为，你知道的，我们是那么好的朋友，而且这段经历充满了乐趣，在很多方面都收获颇丰，方方面面都是如此。但与此同时，对我来说，其中也有一种喜悦。你知道的，当你，你是带着喜悦在哭，因为这甚至不是悲伤，因为我已经准备好了。我已经准备好离开了。所以对于离开我并不感到难过。
We did just watch all of these episodes. We watched the proposal to Holly and the singing goodbye to you and, you know, all the individual goodbyes to all the different people. What a brutal couple of final weeks for you. I mean, were we, did we just cry the whole time? How did we do that? I don't know. I, you know, I could look at it that I'm, I'm, I don't know.
是的。而且对迈克尔来说这感觉很对。是的。不，这，时候到了。而且是时候了，是时候让其他角色走到聚光灯前去继续推进其他的故事线了。这只是，我认为这是正确的，时机对每个人来说都是对的。但与此同时，对于我们共同经历过这一切，对我来说，心中只有一种纯粹的喜悦。
I don't want to make too much of it, but it, it was, it was difficult because, you know, we were such good friends and it had been so much fun and so rewarding in a lot of ways, all ways. But at the same time, there was this, for me, there was a joy to it. You know, when you, you're crying with joy because it wasn't even sadness, like, because I was ready. I was ready to go. And so I wasn't sad about leaving.
而且我有机会和大家一起再绕场一周。最后这几集构建的方式，对我来说感觉非常丰富，既是以迈克尔的身份在告别，同时也是我们作为朋友在这个共同工作的时刻在告别。但，是的，感触良多，那是一种非常情绪化的体验。确实如此。就像那样。我记得那一刻情绪如潮水般向我们涌来。
Yeah. And it felt right for Michael. Yeah. No, it was, it was time. And it was time, it was time for other characters to kind of step to the forefront and other storylines to be pursued. It was just, I think it was the right, it was the timing was right, I think for everybody. But simultaneously, there was just a sense of joy for me that we had experienced all
就像我们前一秒还在大笑，下一秒就要流泪了。但正如你所说，那是因为我们曾有过一段如此美妙的旅程，我们度过了如此快乐的时光。难以置信。简直难以置信。史蒂夫，当人们问我们“和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起工作是什么感觉？”、“史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是个什么样的人？”时，我们总是告诉他们，
of this. And we were getting, I was getting a chance to kind of take a lap with everybody. And the way those last few episodes were structured, it felt very rich to me to kind of simultaneously be saying goodbye as Michael and us as friends in this moment of work together. But yeah, it was a lot, it was a very emotional thing. It was. Like it was. It was just hitting us in waves, I remember.
我们告诉他们他是个普通人，真的，他就是个普通人。所以我们想以一个普通人问答来结束这次采访。好的。好的。普通人问题一，最喜欢的披萨。最喜欢的披萨品牌，比如最喜欢的披萨店。哦天哪，你对披萨很有研究。
Like we would laugh one minute and then we'd be tearing up the next. But like you said, it's because we had had such a great run, we had had such a good time. Incredible. Just incredible. Steve, we are always telling people when they ask us, what was it like to work with Steve Carell? What is Steve Carell like?
我是说，哦，拜托。我们知道你对披萨的热爱。好吧，最喜欢的配料。我要么选择纯奶酪的，要么一半奶酪一半蘑菇加意大利辣香肠。这就是我首选的披萨。但我有很多不同的去处。我有不同类型的披萨，深盘披萨、薄饼底披萨、纽约风味。
And we say he is a regular guy, we're telling you, he is a regular guy. So we thought we would end this interview with a regular guy quiz. Yeah. All right. All right. Regular guy question number one, favorite pizza. Favorite brand of pizza, like favorite pizza place. Oh my gosh, you're very versed in pizza.
洛杉矶还有各种不同风格的披萨，这就是，我算是个行家。下期播客，和史蒂夫一起吃披萨。那就，嘿，你刚刚给了我一个灵感。我要在你们隔壁租个工作室。下一个问题，最喜欢的冰淇淋或冷冻酸奶。我喜欢好的，我算是个基础款爱好者，比如巧克力味。我喜欢好的圣代，比如热巧克力奇巧圣代。好的。
I mean, oh, come on. We know your love of pizza. Well, favorite topping. I will either go with just a plain cheese or maybe do half cheese and then half mushroom and pepperoni. That's my pizza of choice. But I have a lot of different spots. I have different types, the deep dish, the thin crust, the New York style.
相当美味。所以比起冰淇淋本身自带的东西，你更喜欢上面的配料？我不是，是的，混进去的小布朗尼总是很好吃的。好的。但比较基础，比较，我不是那种喜欢把软糖虫和开心果冰淇淋混在一起吃的人。听起来很美味。好吧，让我想想。
There's different LA types of pizzas that are, that's, I'm sort of a connoisseur. Next podcast, pizza with Steve. That's, hey, you just gave me an idea. I'm getting the studio next to yours. Next question, favorite ice cream or frozen yogurt. I like a good, I kind of a basic, like a chocolate. I like good sundae, like a hot fudge sundae. Okay.
你在美国访问过的最喜欢的地方是什么？匹兹堡挺酷的。哦，是吗？是的。我的意思是，我可不是在讽刺，我在那里拍过几部电影，我很喜欢。那是个很酷的城市。好的。
Pretty delicious. So you like a topping more than maybe something in the actual ice cream? I'm not, yeah, brownies mixed in are always good. Okay. But kind of basic, kind of, I don't, I'm not like a gummy worms and pistachio ice cream kind of guy. That sounds delicious. Okay, let's see.
就是这样。我敢打赌这是你第一个想到的。向匹兹堡致敬。向匹兹堡致敬。你最讨厌的运动是什么，或者你最想避免的运动是什么？腹肌。是的。腹肌。
Favorite place you've visited in the United States? Pittsburgh was pretty cool. Oh, yeah? Yeah. I mean, I'm not saying that ironically either, I've done a couple of movies there and I liked it. It was a cool city. All right.
当然。哦。练腿日总是很有趣。我们都喜欢练腿日。谁不喜欢呢？看看我们。我是说，看看我们。我们都喜欢练腿日。
There you go. I bet that's the first one you got. Shout out to Pittsburgh. Shout out to Pittsburgh. What is your least favorite exercise or the exercise you avoid the most? Abs. Yes. Abs.
好吧，是的，我的意思是，仅仅做仰卧起你在我看来，我虽然做，但并不喜欢。好的。你在塔吉特百货买的最后一样东西是什么？我给我儿子买了一个那种小剃须刀，因为他现在开始刮胡子了，而且不是，它就像是一个修剪器。但这是，这是年轻人现在正在使用的东西。好的。他们不用，他们不用刀片。
Of course. Oh. Leg day was always fun. We love a leg day. Who doesn't? Look at us. I mean, look at us. We love a leg day.
我们还没到那个年纪。所以我们不懂。他们不用的，但它就像是，它就像是你可以把它修剪得足够短。这是一个槽点。你完全可以把这个从节目里剪掉。不。
Well, yeah, I mean, just doing sit-ups is that's a, I do it, but I don't love it. All right. What's the last thing you bought at Target? I bought one of those little razors for my son because he's shaving now and it's not, it's like a trimmer. But it's what, it's what's the youths are using now. Okay. They're not, they're not using a blade.
这是我最喜欢的。这是最蠢的回答。我都不知道这叫什么。它就像是，它有点像。我知道你在说什么。它是一个小刀片，你可以用它来。是的。就像胡须修剪器那种东西。你可以，但是，你可以把它修剪得很短，而不用像用电动剃须刀那样，而且。
We're not there yet. So we don't know. They're not using, but it's like, it's like you can trim it close enough. This is a tear. You can definitely lift this from the show. No. This is my favorite. It's the dumbest answer.
哦，大家都走神了。没有。是的。不。大家都换频道了。不。换成别的节目了。史蒂夫。
I don't even know what they're called. It's like, it's sort of a. I know what you're talking about. It's a little blade and you can kind of. Yeah. Like a beard groomer thing. You can, but, but you can cut it really close, but not have to use like an electric razor and.
我想听点音乐。切回披萨的话题。如果你。总之，披萨。最完美的折中。如果你负责做晚饭，你的拿手菜是什么？肉酱意面。好的。
Oh, everyone's tuned out. They're not. Yeah. No. Everyone just changed. No. Change to a different. Steve.
我做的肉酱还算不错。酱汁。你希望精通什么技能？我很想学会弹钢琴。永远不可能实现。但是。你会弹一点钢琴吗？不，完全不会。
I want to listen to some music. Go back to pizza. If you. Anyway, the pizza. The sweet spot. If you are in charge of cooking dinner, what's your go to dish? Spaghetti bolognese. Okay.
所以我们要从零开始。完全是从零开始。好的。你会演奏任何乐器吗？我。我很不好意思地说。我会吹笛子，我还会吹巴里顿号。什么是笛子？
I make a pretty good bolognese. Sauce. What skill would you like to master? I'd love to learn how to play the piano. Never going to happen. But. Do you play the piano in any way? No, not in any way.
是的。哦天哪。那是那种老式的，老式长笛一样的东西吗？对。是的。完全正确。就像1700年代的长笛。匹兹堡和笛子。
So we'd be starting from zero. It's totally from zero. Okay. Do you play any instruments? I. I'm embarrassed. I play the fife and I play the baritone horn. What's a fight?
我真没想到今天会聊到这个。我不仅是个普通人，而且超级无聊。住手。不。住手。好吧。准备好真正展现无聊的一面了吗？哦。
Yeah. Oh God. Is that like ye olde, ye olde flute thing? Yeah. Yeah. It's exactly right. It's like a flute from the 1700s. Hitzberg and the Fife.
你在航班起飞前多久到机场？大概提前两小时。这很符合你的风格。你今天早到了10分钟。我早就知道你会早到。我其实在街区绕了好几圈。我早就准备好了，但我心想，我可不想显得太急切。我和南希去机场总是去得超级早。
I didn't think we'd talk about today. Not only am I sort of an ordinary guy, but super boring. Stop it. No. Stop it. Okay. Ready to really lean into the boring. Oh.
然后我们就在那儿聊天。但这说的是你们俩。你们俩很合拍。那就好。完全如此。好的。是的。而且她经常说，如果她嫁给了一个总是迟到的人，她
How early do you get to the airport before a flight? Like two hours early. That tracks. You were 10 minutes early today. I knew you would be early. And I actually circled the block a few times. I was ready to go, but I'm like, I don't want to seem too eager. Nancy and I get, we get to the airport so early.
肯定已经离婚了，因为这会。这对他非常重要。非常重要。守时。但对我们俩来说都是如此。是的。而且我宁愿在机场坐一个半小时，也不愿意在车里急得焦头烂额，生怕赶不上飞机。
And we just, we were just talking. But it's both of you though. You're in sync. That's good. Totally. Okay. Yes. And she's often said, if she had been married to someone who was like always late, she would
好的。你最喜欢的鸡尾酒或成人饮料是什么？我不怎么喝酒。我偶尔会喝一杯葡萄酒之类的，但我不能说我有最喜欢的鸡尾酒。我不是，我只是不太经常喝酒。我们要推荐迈克尔的饮品，也就是苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我们可没开玩笑。
have gotten a divorce because it would have. It's very important to her. Very. Punctuality. But for both of us. Yes. And I would rather sit in the airport for an hour and a half than be like getting all worked up in the car that we're going to make, not make our flight.
我们绝对没开玩笑。就在节目里。史蒂夫，它真的很好。非常不错。真的吗？是的。珍娜拿过来的。没开玩笑。
All right. What is your favorite cocktail or adult beverage? I don't drink a lot. I will occasionally have a glass of wine or something, but I can't say that I have a cocktail. I'm not, I'm just not a big drinker. We would like to recommend Michael's drink, which is the Scotch and Splenda. We're not kidding.
就像开玩笑一样。当时我想，这尝起来肯定恶心透了。我们在干什么？我们给每个人都调制了一杯。然后我们尝了一口，天哪，其实还挺好喝的。我想在酒吧里点一杯，但我，我有点怕，因为。好吧，你得给它起个名字。与其叫苏格兰威士忌加代糖，你叫它“苏格兰代糖威士忌”吗？
We're not kidding. Here on the show. Steve, it is excellent. It's very good. Really? Yes. Jenna brought it in. No joke.
我知道，迈克尔不是给它起过一个名字吗，我们记不清叫什么了。我不知道。是的，他确实给它起过一个名字。威士忌代糖特饮。难道不叫代糖苏格兰特饮吗？就叫特饮。是的。一种特饮。
Like as a joke. And I was like, this is going to be disgusting. What are we doing? We made them for everybody. And we were like, damn, it's actually pretty good. I want to order one at a bar, but I'm, I'm scared to because. Well, you have to come up with a name for it. Instead of Scotch and Splenda, do you call it a Scotch-ta?
也许叫特饮。哦，这名字不错。听起来可不太美味。它其实很好喝。是的。请给我来一杯特饮。你知道吗？干脆。
I know didn't, didn't Michael have a name for it and we can't remember what it is. I don't know. Yeah, he does have a name for it. A splotch. Wasn't it a Splenda and Scott? It's splotch. Yeah. A splotch.
我什么时候一定要尝尝特饮。太好了。好的。下次。我们三个要聚一聚。我们要喝一杯特饮。我们要去喝特饮。
Maybe a splotch. Oh, that's good. It doesn't sound delicious. It's very good. Yeah. I'll take a splotch, please. You know what? Straight up.
你的工具箱里都有些什么，你拿的是什么工具？大约三天前，我在组装……我太尴尬了。你这是要说你在组装一个鸟屋吗？更糟糕。我买了一个吸尘器，一个户外落叶吸尘器，它还可以把落叶粉碎。我不得不从工具箱里拿工具来组装它。我订购的货到了，我必须把它组装起来，把那个小袋子安上。你清理落叶吗？
I'll try a splotch at some point. Great. All right. Okay. Next time. The three of us are going to get together. And we have one splotch. We're going to go splotching.
嗯，我也有一个吹叶机。我做的是，我用吹叶机把落叶吹成一堆，然后我拿出我的吸尘粉碎机把它们吸进去并粉碎落叶。然后我把落叶收集起来，把它们铺在我们的花坛里。哦，天哪。这就是长笛和披萨，原味披萨，巧克力冰淇淋。这就是我。是的。
What was your toolbox and what tool did you grab? About three days ago, I was putting... I am so embarrassed. Are you about to say you're putting together a bird feeder? Worse. I bought a vacuum, an outdoor leaf vacuum, which also mulches the leaves. And I had to go to my toolbox to put it together. I ordered it and it arrived and I had to assemble it and put the little bag on it. Do you blow leaves?
你的工具有哪些？你拿了什么工具？大约三天前，我在组装……我太不好意思了。你该不会要说你在组装鸟屋吧？更糟。我买了一个吸尘器，一个户外落叶吸尘器，它还可以把树叶打碎成覆盖物。我得去工具箱拿工具来组装它。我订购了它，它送到了，我必须组装它并把小袋子装上去。你吹树叶吗？
Well, I have a leaf blower, too. What I do is I use the leaf blower to blow them into a pile and then I take my vacuum mulcher and I vacuum them up and mulch the leaves. And then I take the leaves and I put them in our planting beds. Oh, my God. And so that's the fife and pizza, plain, chocolate ice cream. And that's me. Yeah.
嗯，我也有一个吹叶机。我的做法是，我用吹叶机把它们吹成一堆，然后我拿我的吸叶碎叶机把它们吸起来并打碎。接着我把这些树叶拿来铺在我们的花坛里。哦，天哪。所以这就是笛子和披萨，原味，巧克力冰淇淋。那就是我。是的。
And we all do it in Pittsburgh. Barrel of laughs. I'm in love with you. Well, clearly the bar is low because there's not. I can't even believe that Nancy decided to marry me with like that as a track record. That is the that is that's pretty bad. Like when you do interviews like this and you say things and you hear yourself reflected in the words, how you're describing yourself, I think I'm like more interesting than that.
我们所有人都在匹兹堡这么干过。真是笑死人了。我爱死你了。好吧，显然标准很低，因为根本没有。我简直不敢相信南茜竟然决定嫁给我，就凭我以前那些黑历史。这真的是，真的是太糟糕了。就像当你做这种采访，说出那些话，然后听到自己说出口的词，听到你如何形容自己时，我觉得自己好像比那更有趣一些。
But clearly I'm not. I don't know how to play the piano. No. What would you like to do? I'd like to be smart and play the piano, but instead I'm mulching leaves and playing the fife. So. Okay.
但显然我并不是。我甚至不会弹钢琴。不。你想做什么？我想变得聪明然后弹钢琴，但相反我却在给树叶覆盖护根物，还吹着横笛。所以。好吧。
Is there anything in your career that you haven't done that you'd like to do or in your life? Because like Jenna, for example, yes, you know, it is my dream to one day do theater and win a Tony Award. Yes. This is my I would love to do this in my life. My dream is I really want one of those hats that has big flowers on it that hummingbirds eat out of.
你的职业生涯中有什么还没做过但想去做的事吗？或者生活中有什么？因为就像珍娜一样，是的，你知道的，我一生的梦想就是有一天能去演戏剧并赢得托尼奖。是的。这就是我的，我这辈子真的很想做这件事。我的梦想是，我真的很想要一顶那种上面有大花朵、蜂鸟会在上面采蜜的帽子。
So that's Jenna wants to work towards a Tony. I want to work towards a hummingbird eating out of my hat. Where do you land? Those are very disparate dreams. Well, I don't even know how to top that. Honestly, boy, I'm so content with certainly my professional life. It's been I've been so lucky. I can't maybe do a play at some point.
所以这就是珍娜想朝着托尼奖努力。我想朝着有蜂鸟在我的帽子上采蜜努力。你呢？这些是很不一样的梦想。好吧，老实说，我甚至不知道怎么超越那个。天哪，我对我的职业生活真的很满足。我已经，我太幸运了。也许什么时候能演个话剧吧。
Would you ever do theater? Yeah. Yeah. And and I've, you know, I've been talking to a couple of theaters about maybe doing something. Yeah. Maybe somewhere down the road. I haven't done a play and well, since Nancy and I got married, it's been 27 years since
你会演戏剧吗？会。会。而且，你知道的，我一直在和几家剧院聊关于可能做点什么的事。也许吧，在未来的某个时候。我很久没演过话剧了，自从我和南茜结婚以来，已经有27年了。
I've done play. So. But you are a classically trained actor. Oh, yes. Yes. You, you were, you were of all of us. We always talk about how like there were a bunch of the people who were the theater nerds.
我没演过话剧了。所以。但你是一个受过古典训练的演员。哦，对。是的。你，你是，你是我们所有人当中。我们总是谈论，就像有一群人他们是戏剧书呆子。
And then there were the like comedy sketch comedy improv nerds on our set. But you were both you studied theater and also I was just a nerd. You double nerded it is what I'm getting at. You did both. Yeah. I was. Yeah. I would like to do.
然后还有在我们剧组里的喜剧小品、即兴喜剧书呆子。但你两者都是，你学过戏剧，而且我也是个书呆子。我的意思是，你双重书呆子了。你两样都会。是的。我是。是的。我很想去做。
I, I'm with you. I'd like to do some. Maybe we should do something together. Let's do it. Oh, I would do some Broadway. I would come and watch it with your hat. And finally, Steve, you just worked with Mr. John Krasinski on his movie if how was it to team up with him again?
我，我和你一样。我也想做点。也许我们应该一起做点什么。我们干吧。哦，我会去演百老汇。我会戴着你的帽子去看。最后，史蒂夫，你刚刚和约翰·卡拉辛斯基先生合作了他的电影《神秘友友》，再次和他合作感觉怎么样？
Really fun. Was that great? Well, I'm supposed to contractually, I'm supposed to say. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Do you need to get out the piece of paper? Do you want to read directly from it?
真的很有趣。很棒吗？好吧，按合同规定我应该这么说。对。对。你需要把那张纸拿出来吗？你想直接从上面读吗？
John Krasinski is the most wonderful. It was great. He's and he was such a good director. I mean, obviously, since the office boy, has he really shown himself as a fine director? But did you know Janusz Kaminski is his DP on this movie? No. Who is Steven Spielberg's DP? Like he is the best director of photography in the business.
约翰·卡拉辛斯基是最棒的。太棒了。他，他是个非常好的导演。我的意思是，很显然，自从《办公室》以来，他真的展现出自己是一个优秀的导演了吗？但你知道扬斯·卡米斯基是这部电影的摄影指导吗？不知道。谁是斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的摄影指导？就像他是业内最好的摄影指导。
He's a legend. And so, you know, wow, that's it. It's a huge deal. And I think such a sign of respect to John, right? This person wants to, you know, wanted to work together with him. So that's I, yeah, he's he's a he's an amazing, he's a big deal. Amazingly talented guy. And so, yeah, I'm just great to see him like you guys.
他是个传奇。所以，你知道，哇，就是这样。这是件大事。而且我认为这对约翰来说是一个极大的尊重，对吧？这个人想要，你知道的，想要和他一起合作。所以这就是，是的，他是一个，他是一个了不起的，是个大人物。非常有才华的人。所以，是的，看到他就像你们一样，真的很棒。
It's like, wow, yeah, exactly like the last time we saw each other. There's like no time is past. We definitely felt that too. Like when he zoomed in, we were just cracking up. We had to like stop laughing so we could do like our interview with him because we just got so tickled. I love that. This is, you know, BJ was on and he said to us, he was like, you guys office family forever.
就像，哇，是的，就像我们上次见面一样。就像时间没有流逝一样。我们绝对也有这种感觉。就像他视频连线进来时，我们都在大笑。我们不得不停止大笑，好让我们能对他进行采访，因为我们笑得太开心了。我喜欢这样。这就是，你知道的，BJ之前来过，他对我们说，他说你们是永远的办公室大家庭。
And that's absolutely how I feel like family. Thanks for coming, Steve. Yeah, whatever. Oh, sorry, you got to get back to your leaf mulching. Geez, got a busy day there. Oh, man, you don't know the half of it. Oh, well, truly, thank you. Yes, thank you.
我绝对就是这种感觉，就像一家人一样。谢谢你来，史蒂夫。对，随便啦。哦，抱歉，你得回去给树叶铺护根物了。天哪，今天还挺忙的呢。哦，老实说，你根本不懂这有多忙。哦，好吧，真的非常感谢。是的，谢谢你。
So good to see you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
很高兴见到你们。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科克。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。